Now we're older, everyone's moved on, but I remember Twitch chat from those days that are gone.
Twitchy moans from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitchy moan.
It's been a minute since I tasted blood.
I remember typing Dan's game.
Forehead swift rage, PJ, salt and fail fish.
Life was easy, spamming all the time.
TOS was nowhere, so everyone's feeling fine.
Twitchy moans from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Keep a forehead, Bible thumb, Twitchy moan.
Still hear his bark in the morning hour he calls me.
His doggy emote reminds me of a time far away.
Looking at a chat I get a feeling that I miss emotes from yesterday, yesterday.
Twitchy moans from long ago, made you feel you're not alone.
Pong is pong jam, cap is capa, Bible thumb, Twitchy moans.
So, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob Windows diesmal die Audio-Settings beibehalten hat, aber es sieht fast so aus.
Pog aus Windows hat was geschafft zu speichern.
Es ist unglaublich, man hat es gar nicht mehr möglich gehalten.
So, als erstes gucken wir uns heute mal, also entweder gucken wir, ich bin mir noch ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, was wir als erstes gucken wollen.
Entweder gucken wir ein Battlefield-Topplay-Video, in der Hoffnung, dass ich meins endlich jetzt mal fertig kriege.
Ich hab mir gesagt, dieses Wochenende kommt's, bleibt's ja nur noch heute.
Ja, und als nächstes, wir könnten uns ein Modern Warfare 2-Review angucken, weil ich bin ja mal gespannt, ob man das überhaupt erkennt, was sie da remastered haben.
Da hab ich so meine Zweifel, ob man das wirklich erkennt.
Das hat für mich, ich hab's nicht ausprobiert, das hat so wie der übelste Low-Effort-Versuch ausgesehen.
So, nachdem auch so, ja, wir haben jetzt Modern Warfare rausgebracht, das heißt, für die Kacknoobs, die keine Ahnung haben, bringen wir jetzt Modern Warfare 2 Remastered aus, weil das einfach gut passt.
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine, so Activision-Logik, aktuell ist Modern Warfare Remastered, also nein, Rebooted, Modern Warfare Rebooted ist ja gerade aktuell.
Und jetzt bringt man Modern Warfare 2 Remastered raus, was keine Sau checkt von den Kacknoobs und sich das kauft und denkt, das wäre quasi die Kampagnen-Fortsetzung von Modern Warfare.
Was ja auch so ist, aber von Modern Warfare 1 und nicht etwa von Modern Warfare Rebooted.
Alles klar.
Die haben damit garantiert gehofft, noch ein bisschen Zeug zu verkaufen, garantiert.
Es hat kein Multiplayer dabei, ja.
Ja, es ist, ähm, wo hatten wir denn das Battlefield-Top-Place-Video? Irgendwo hatte ich, ich hab's hier irgendwo.
Ja, da.
Schon mal Competitive Programming-Videos angeschaut? Ja, vor zwei Tagen oder so, im Stream. KegW.
Der Modern Warfare 2 Multiplayer war gar nicht so toll, wie man das in Erinnerung hat.
Der war eigentlich genauso kacke wie jeder andere außer MW1. Also MW1 war okay, Black Ops 1 war okay.
Code 4 und 5 war auch noch irgendwo okay. Der Rest war einfach Rage, äh, Rage-erzeugender Kack.
MW2 ist nur so beliebt noch in den Köpfen der Leute, weil es halt eines der ersten Games in dieser Richtung war, wo es komplett over the top war.
Also wo ja wirklich mal alles random passieren konnte, was passieren kann.
Kennst du How to Land a Space Shuttle? Ich glaube schon, wenn das so ein Vortrag ist, wo irgendjemand das rekonstruiert hat und auch ein paar...
Ja, doch, das kenne ich. Das ist keine Simulation im Eigensinn. Der Typ, der fliegt quasi in eine Simulation und hält einen Torque da drüber.
Dann kenne ich das. Ja, das kenne ich. Das ist aber schon älter, das habe ich schon drei Jahre mal geguckt.
Oh Leute, ich muss den Chat-Log anmachen, sonst sehe ich ja gar nichts mehr.
Ich muss ein APFS-Laufwerk in die Linux einbinden, komme aber nicht weiter.
Was ist APFS? Klingt nach Apple. Ist das Apple?
APFS?
Apple? Keine Ahnung. Da gibt es doch garantiert irgendein Fuse-Modul oder so.
How to Mount Mac OS? Ist das sogar der LinuxNewbieGuide.org? Da kann ja nichts mal schief gehen, oder?
Read-Only, da reicht der wahrscheinlich. Ja, gibt eine Fuse. Oh fuck, man muss sich die selbst kompilieren.
Ja, warum nicht? Also wenn das keine allzu großen Dependencies hat, ist es kein großer Akt, sich den Kram selbst zu kompilieren,
wenn das natürlich 20 Milliarden Dependencies hat, dann ist es nicht so schön.
Das macht eigentlich kurz das Corona-Update.
Das macht eigentlich so das Corona-Update. Ah, yes, wir sind jetzt auf Platz 4. Exzellent.
Ja, also den Chinesen glaube ich ja kein Wort, in dem Fall, dass die keine neuen Ansteckungen haben, das kann ich mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen.
Oder die machen so wie, was habe ich letztens gelesen in, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wo es war.
Ich sage jetzt einfach mal Thailand, aber ich glaube es war nicht Thailand, es war irgendwas in der Richtung.
Da habe ich irgendeinen News-Artikel drüber gelesen, so nach dem Motto, okay Quarantäne, wer rausgeht wird erschossen.
Habe ich auch gedacht, exzellent, so kann man es auch machen, da geht garantiert keiner raus.
So, ich muss keine alten Fragen löschen.
Ne, dann, ich habe APFS noch nie versucht, Unterlidung zum Laufen zu bringen, keine Ahnung.
War das Südkorea? Ne, glaube ich nicht.
Glaube ich auch nicht, Südkorea, die sind da eigentlich nicht so barbarisch, nicht so heftig veranlagt in der Richtung.
Und die kriegen den Kram ja auch frei, Japan kriegt den Kram frei, will ich ja auch ziemlich gut hin.
Gestern, Leute, wieder, ey, ich fasse es nicht, ne.
Zwei Sachen gestern, muss ich euch gleich mal erzählen.
Ich muss mir aber erstmal kurz hier was aufschreiben, dass ich es nicht vergesse.
Ich will nicht den Video Editor starten, Windows, meine Güte.
Gestern am Main lang gelaufen und ich habe mich echt wieder gefragt, was mit den Leuten los ist, ne.
Die haben, an jeder Ecke saßen irgendwelche Dreier, Vierer, Grüppchen rum.
Und sie haben im Vorfeld ja schon gesagt, dass sie am Main und generell an so Plätzen, wo viele Leute sind,
dass sie da öfters mit der Polizei vorbeigucken wollen, was sich in Deutschland so formuliert,
also was sie so formuliert haben ist, die Polizei wird darauf achten, diese Gebiete besonders zu bestreifen.
Also, die Polizei bestreift bei uns demnächst den Main, beziehungsweise den Weg am Main.
Das Video vom MyLab ist echt gut, hatte ich was gemacht zu Monka Corona.
Corona geht jetzt erst los, ja, das können wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Die macht immer recht stichhaltige Videos, das finde ich gut.
Zumindest habe ich nicht einmal Polizei am Main gesehen, was aber noch viel lustiger ist,
neben den Spasten, die es nicht checken und da irgendwie mit drei, vier Leuten rumhocken.
Aber wenn ich mir die Kandidaten angegucke, die da mit drei bis vier Leuten rumgesessen haben,
da war überall, wie sagt man so schön, bildungsferne Schichten unterwegs.
Besondere bildungsferne Schichten waren da hauptsächlich unterwegs.
Ich habe auch gedacht, die checken es wahrscheinlich einfach nicht.
Ja, das kostet Geld, ich glaube das kostet teilweise bis zu 250 Euro pro Person.
Also ich bin auch der Meinung, die sollen das machen.
Es kann ja nicht sein, dass sich 90% oder 95% der Leute da ordentlich dran halten
und dafür sorgen, dass das sich nicht so extrem ausbreitet, wie es sich sonst ausbreiten würde.
Und ein paar verkacken es dann voll. Das kann doch wirklich nicht sein.
Generation Bushido, das ist noch nicht mal Generation Haftbefehl.
Was gibt es denn da noch? Was gibt es da noch Dümmeres?
Ich kenne mich da mit Deutschrap-Geschichten nicht aus.
Generation, wie hieß der Typ letztens? Du kack Fanboy mit dem Polizist.
Wie hieß der Typ? Jesus? Nee, das war ein anderer.
Nee, das war nicht Mero, das war ein anderer Typ. Du kack Fanboy. War das Flair?
Das war glaube ich, das war glaube ich Flair. Flair war das.
Das ist eher Generation Jesus und Flair, was da am Main rumhängt.
Das sind also, wie gesagt, besonders bildungsferne Schichten, sind da am Start.
Und was auch geil war, im Rewe letztens wieder, war so eine Oma am Start,
die voll auf so Privatpolizei gemacht hat.
Nee, was heißt Oma? Das war keine Oma. Die war vielleicht, keine Ahnung, 50 oder so.
Wenn ich überlege, 15 Jahre bin ich auch 50, ja.
Zumindest standen da auch ein paar Menschen vom Rewe rum und da hat sie sich übelst aufgeregt.
Das kann doch nicht sein. Sie hat sie mit dem Handy jetzt aufgenommen und soll sie es etwa der Polizei schicken.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich schlimmer finde.
So die Leute, die sich übelst aufspielen oder die so dämlich sind und sich nicht daran halten.
Eigentlich finde ich die Leute, die sich nicht daran halten, schlimmer.
Weil ich weiß, was bleibt dir denn anders übrig, wenn Polizei nicht am Start ist?
Und dir das auf den Sack geht, als was rumzumeckern.
Was willst du machen? Was anderes kannst du ja nicht machen.
Du kannst die ja schlecht alle jetzt umhauen und bei der Polizei vorbeifahren.
Geht schlecht. Das gucken wir uns später an. Fand ich ein bisschen lustig.
Ja und das zweite, was ich erzählen wollte, ist typisch Frankfurt.
Typisch Frankfurt. Ich muss mal überlegen, ob ich das jetzt überhaupt noch zusammenkriege.
Da hat einer am Fenster, eine, eine hat am Fenster gestanden.
Hat sich eben nachher dann rausgestellt, Drogenabhängige.
Und ich laufe am Fenster vorbei und das erste, was ich höre ist, die steht am Fenster und telefoniert übelst laut.
Und hat dann so gesagt, ich habe meine Oma geschlagen und ich habe meine Mutter mit Pisse übergossen.
Aber ich kann nichts dafür. Ist jetzt Quot, Quot.
Aber ich kann nichts dafür. Ich wurde aufgehetzt. Ich stand unter Drogen.
Wortwörtlich. Zitat, Alter. Wortwörtlich.
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, was geht jetzt ab?
Läufst du irgendwo am Fenster vorbei und die erste, und die erste erzählt so nach dem Worte,
ich habe meine Oma mit Pisse, äh, ich habe meine Oma geschlagen und meine Mutter mit Pisse übergossen.
What the fuck? Was ist mit den Leuten los?
Und es ist garantiert, also es ist garantiert wieder jemand, der sich keiner Schuld bewusst ist.
Weil die hat ja auch gesagt, ich kann nichts dafür, ich wurde aufgehetzt.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, ich könnte wirklich sehr aufgehetzt sein.
Und ich würde im Leben nicht meine Oma schlagen, wenn sie noch leben würde und an meine Mutter mit Pisse verkießen.
Was soll das jetzt überhaupt für eine Ausrede sein?
Ich wurde aufgehetzt. So nach dem Motto, ja, ähm, da hat jemand fünf Leute überfallen,
aber da wurde aufgehetzt, da kann ja nichts dafür. Was eine bescheuerte, was eine bescheuerte, äh, low brain Antwort, Alter.
Hast du ein anderes Mik? Ich habe ein bisschen, letztes Mal ein bisschen, äh, Kompressorsettings eingestellt.
Und es war eigentlich die einhellige Meinung des Streams, dass das jetzt deutlich besser klingt als vorher.
Äh, ich muss mein Noisegate noch anmachen, fällt mir auf.
In der Hoffnung, in der Hoffnung, dass es jetzt nicht, das müssen wir mal ausbringen, ob das mit dem Noisegate rumspackt.
Ähm, das Noisegate ist viel zu, viel zu wenig sensitiv eingestellt.
Das geht gar nicht aus.
Lul.
Normalerweise sollte es ausgehen, kann ich nachher noch ein bisschen genauer einstellen.
Da kann ich es wahrscheinlich sogar auslassen, das macht jetzt keinen großen Unterschied.
Ähm, das Fried Rice Video, was, wo haben wir Fried Rice? Da, Four Levels of Fried Rice.
Amateur to Food Scientist. Food Scientist klingt eher so nach, ähm, veganem Ernährungsberater.
Oh, wir brauchen noch, ganz wichtig, wir brauchen noch eine Sache, brauchen wir noch, brauchen wir noch im Meme Board.
EnemyAC130Above.
Wichtig, ganz wichtig.
Ähm, youtube.dl-f und jetzt laden wir uns nur die Waff-Datei runter.
Falls es da ein Waff gibt, gibt es gar keine Waff, was gibt es denn da?
M4A.
Ist auch was mit ordentlicher Qualität.
Ich glaube, mein Meme Board frisst kein M4A, das habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, aber Waff frisst es.
Geht es dem Friseur? Dem Friseur geht es gut. Der spielt die ganze Zeit irgendwelche komischen Browser Games.
AC130.Waff.
So, jetzt probieren wir das Ganze mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Äh, wo ist es? Stream AC130.Waff.
Hä?
Ist es Punkt Waff oder muss es Punkt Wave sein?
Nee.
Punkt Waff.
Hä?
Windows.
Wo ist das Problem?
Ich kann kein Waff mehr abspieler.
Warum nicht?
Ja, ist das laut.
Viel zu laut. WTF, da fliegen die an die Ohren weg.
Excellent.
Ja, das können wir jetzt lassen. Kann ich nachher noch leiser machen. Wunderbar. Excellent.
Warum kann ich in kein Waff mehr abspielen? Was ist denn das?
Invalid Value? Was? Es ist eine Waff-Datei.
Okay, aber M2T.
Wow, wow, wow, wow. Ah, ah.
WTF ist mit meinem Sound los?
Alter.
Meine Fresse.
Oh.
Ai, ai, ai.
Ich würde mal sagen, ist mein Audio im Arsch irgendwie?
Ach, du Scheiße.
Was geht mit meinem Audio ab?
Okay, warte mal, ich muss mal ein bisschen leiser machen. Nicht, dass es nochmal passiert.
Warum kann ich kein Waff abspielen? Ah, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Wir machen einfach excellent VLC, dann geht das.
Mit Windows Media Player kann man das abspielen, oder?
Was ist eigentlich mit Windows los? Warum geht kein Waff mehr?
Wie stellt man das jetzt in Windows ein, dass man...
The Groove Player. So, use always.
Was ist mit dem Kram kaputt? Windows, please.
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt machen. Ich muss gerade ein bisschen Windows flamen, das ist schon Waff.
Invalid Registry.
How to fix invalid value for registry problem. Invalid value for opening videos.
Okay, ah, yes.
Aha, 30 Milliarden Sachen.
Was ist mit Windows, Windows? Ich hab da eigentlich überhaupt keinen Bock, den Scheiß zu fixen.
Vor allem, okay, probieren wir mal was aus. Groove, wir starten das von Hand.
Ich hab doch ein VLC installiert. Aber ich will nur wissen, warum Windows nicht in der Lage ist, ein Waff abzuspielen.
Okay, track and drop ist zu modern für diese Anwendung. Das geht nicht.
Das wäre ja auch undenkbar, ne?
Dass man ein Stück Musik in eine Datei tracken droppen könnte und die würde das abspielen.
Das kann ja nicht sein. Das geht nicht.
Wie öffnet man in diesem Kackprogramm Dinger?
Songs.
Wie edit man hier überhaupt Musik?
Windows, warum ist deine Software so scheiße?
Ich will einfach Musik öffnen.
Windows, Alter.
Ist das mal ernsthaft? Habt ihr eine Ahnung, wie man hier einfach eine Datei öffnet?
Wie öffnet man eine Datei?
Ich will einfach nur... Wahrscheinlich muss ich mich... Track and drop geht nicht.
Wahrscheinlich muss man sich erstmal mit seinem Microsoft-Account irgendwie verbinden oder so.
Warum auch immer.
Now playing.
Fick dich, Windows.
Aber wisst ihr, was funktioniert, was das Lustige ist?
Überhaupt kein Problem.
VLC geht einfach.
Aber warum geht das nicht mit diesem Kack?
My music.
Nothing to show hier.
Kann man jetzt hier reintracken? Nein, natürlich nicht.
Okay, wir machen jetzt wieder größte Kacken.
Playlist. Neue Playlist. Create Playlist.
So, Playlist.
Add.
Mein Gott, man kann nicht mal in eine Playlist was reintrocknen.
Windows.
Ich will keine Musikbibliothek oder sonst was hinzufügen.
Ich will einfach eine Datei öffnen.
Eine Datei.
Open file in Groove Music.
Aggressionstherapie, when?
Da muss ich Linux verwenden.
Endlich will ich die Groove Music App.
Ist mir zu dumm jetzt. Ist mir echt zu dumm.
Habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt machen?
Open mit.
Warum steht denn da der VLC überhaupt nicht drin?
VLC, okay.
Wo ist mein VLC?
Warum ist das unter Windows alles so extrem kompliziert und scheiße gemacht?
Choose another app.
Okay, ist nicht drinne.
Look on PC.
Zag.
VLC.
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Always use VLC.
Easy.
Wir öffnen jetzt einfach alles mit VLC.
Und schon funktioniert's.
Scheiß auf den Microsoft Kram.
Also auch immer der für Schmerzen hat, dass Waffdateien nicht in Groove Music geöffnet werden können.
Das ist wirklich massivst keck weh, Alter.
Das ist keck weh kleines Zahne.
iTunes.
Das wird immer schlimmer.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Wenn ich jemand auch gleich sagen Datenschutz, dann würde ich sagen, ich habe gar nicht aufgenommen.
Dann musst du mir erst mal erklären, dass es doch der Fall ist.
Gucken wir nachher.
Du solltest mal schauen, was die Polizei München auf Twitter für Fragen beantworten muss.
Darf ich auf den Spielplatz, dass ich nicht raus, sondern nur der Spielplatz wird man auch gerne dürfen.
Ich will nicht Polizei sein aktuell, weil die Leute, also generell unsere Mitmenschen, egal wo auf der Welt, sind einfach dumm.
Menschen sind einfach dumm.
Bis auf so vielleicht 0,5 Prozent, die sind nicht dumm.
Aber der Rest ist dumm.
Mit denen musste ich halt rumschlagen.
Das heißt, nachdem die Welt ja eh nur 80.000 Einwohner hat, sind wahrscheinlich die 5 Prozent auch alle bei mir im Twitch Chat.
Die meisten Leute sind nicht nur pepega, die sind extrem pepega und auch noch dämlich.
Quickmaps.
Mit was wollten wir anfangen zu gucken?
Das Battlefield-Topplay-Video.
Wo habe ich es denn?
Hier, das da.
1000 IQ.
Wir wollten mit Doppelfield anfangen.
Doppelfield, das wäre doch mal ein guter Name für neues Battlefield, oder?
Die wissen immer noch nicht, wie sie ihre Teile nennen sollen.
Mittlerweile ist ja die Benamung der Battlefield-Teile ungefähr genauso beknackt wie die Benamung der Xbox-Konsolen bei Microsoft.
Also es checkt auch keiner mehr.
Das nächste nicht einfach, anscheinend Battlefield 2 Doppelfield.
Dann blickt es keiner mehr durch.
So, machen wir mal Musik aus.
Hast du das mit den Playlists bei Battlefield 5 mitbekommen mit der UI?
Ja, das habe ich auf Reddit gelesen.
Es hat letztens im Stream einer gepostet und zwar war das doch das,
wo der Entwickler sagt, dass man das UI von Battlefield 5 hardcoded hat.
Also die Technologie ist nicht da, um neue Playlists einzufügen in Battlefield 5.
Ich finde die Antwort mittlerweile, das ist so eine Standardantwort, was viele Technikunternehmen und so sagen.
Technology is not there yet.
Wo ich mir so denke, ja okay, aber vor 20 Jahren ging das doch schon.
Warum ist denn heute die Technologie nicht da für irgendwas?
Sind halt keine echten Hacker-Mans mehr am Start.
Ich muss euch mal ein Video angucken, wo sie von der Entwicklung von Quake und Doom und sonst was erzählen.
Da sagt einer wortwörtlich, ich weiß nicht mehr welcher von denen das war, sagt fast wortwörtlich,
sowas wie Burnout gab es bei ihm nicht.
Er hat auf dem Klo gesessen und sich geärgert, dass er nicht weiterprogrammieren konnte.
Hat einer in einem Talk erzählt, der damals bei Quake mitentwickelt hat.
Er hat sich geärgert, dass er nicht weiterprogrammieren konnte, weil er aufs Klo musste.
Und dementsprechend hat er sich irgendwann sowas aufs Klo gestellt, dass er quasi beim Kacken programmieren konnte.
Da gab es keinen Burnout.
Die waren einfach ganz scharf drauf. Das waren halt noch richtig echte Hacker-Mans.
Okay, da stellt er sich an auf Dema-Went-Peak.
Das war Set-Up, oder? War das Set-Up?
Wobei das war kein Set-Up. Die Leute sind wirklich so dumm auf Dema-Went-Peak und stehen da vorne und snipen.
Das könnte auch Set-Up gewesen sein.
Ich halte es immer zu gut. Wahrscheinlich ist es legit.
Weil die ganzen Typen, die da oben rumgammeln, die ganzen Sniper-Dudes, das ist halt auf Dema-Went-Peak so.
Allerdings ist es schon ein bisschen sehr auffällig, dass gar keiner runterspringt.
Vielleicht ist es auch Set-Up.
Trotzdem eine nice Sache.
Vor allem, warum schießen die jetzt auf den? Was erwarten die denn?
Hello and welcome to the Battlefield Top Plays.
In todays Episode, we have a selection of epic Battlefield clips, starting out with a song from Battlefield 4.
This is an amazing clip, from our Mob.
Jawoll! Das ist immer nice, wenn die in den Blumen rausgeschreibt werden.
With a snipe, as calm as you like.
Moving on, it's Peanut Rule.
Lohnt sich eine Nvidia Shield noch? Kann ich gleich was zu sagen? Aber prinzipiell schon, ja.
Ich finde die neue Shield halt protestlich.
Diesen Zigaretten-Anzünder.
Ich weiß nicht, was... So, ich muss mal kurz... Das muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was mit Nvidia in dem Fall los ist.
Ähm, hier.
Das neue Shield.
Was reitet jemand von einer so schönen Box...
So was zu machen?
Warum?
Es ist mir unbegreiflich.
Es war so eine schöne Box, ja.
Wann kommt dein Epic Battlefields-Moment her? Ich hoffe heute.
Es gibt zwei Varianten. Entweder setze ich mich hin direkt nach dem Stream und mach das.
Oder ich programmier noch ein bisschen weiter und mach's nicht.
So, warum macht man von so einer schönen Box?
Warum macht man da so einen Zigaretten-Anzünder draus?
Vor allem, die Box, die konnte man ja wenigstens noch neben den Fernsehstellen.
Die konnte man neben den Fernsehstellen. Ich mein, ich... Max FPS, Wohnzimmer.
Kannst euch ja zeigen, wie das Ganze aussieht. Ich hab ja mal ein Video von gemacht, von meinem Setup im Wohnzimmer.
Und da sieht man hier neben, da unten in der Ecke, steht das Shield.
Ja, da unten sieht man's ja. Ich glaub, ich zoom irgendwann noch mal ran.
Du kannst das schön unter den Fernsehstellen und gut ist.
Ja, übrigens spiegel ich mich hier so sehr, weil immer gefragt wird, Max, wie siehst du aus?
Guckt euch einfach das Video an, dann wisst ihr's.
Ich spiegel mich da so oft drin.
Das ist ja auch klar am Ende.
So, und jetzt ist man auf die Idee gekommen, wir haben eine schöne kleine Box, die man schön unter den Fernsehstellen kann.
Wir machen daraus eine Röhre, die man nicht mehr hinstellen kann.
Das ist das einzige, dafür hat man jetzt die Fernbedienung dreieckig gemacht.
Triangle. Die kann man jetzt schön hinlegen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass man eine flache Fernbedienung von früher nicht auch hinlegen konnte, aber was auch immer.
Ein Nachteil von dieser Fernbedienung ist auch noch, dass man nicht mehr gescheit draufdrücken kann,
wenn man auf dem Sofa liegt und die Fernbedienung neben einem liegt.
Es sei denn, man hat die vorher extra so schön hingewinkelt, dass man gerade...
Also, es ist nicht unbedingt die große Usability-Innovation gewesen, was sie sich hier ausgedacht haben.
Also quasi von sowas zu sowas.
Naja.
So, wir gucken jetzt weiter, Battlefield.
Denn den Netflix-Button brauch ich nicht.
Ich hab's eh so gemacht, muss ich tatsächlich noch mal zurück.
Ich hab's eh so gemacht mit...
Ursprünglich hatte ich die hier.
Ursprünglich hatte ich die hier und ich hab damals schon die Buttons remapped.
Und zwar...
Sieht man die vielleicht ein bisschen größer.
Den Alexa- bzw. Google-Assistent-Button verwende ich eh nie.
Das lag zum größten Teil auch ursprünglich daran, dass Kodi und alle anderen Programme,
außer eben das Dashboard, keine gescheite Google-Assistent-Integration haben.
Die Google-Assistent-Integration auf Android-TV ist eh nur ja sehr abgespeckt.
Und außerdem bin ich kein großer Fan von Sprachbedienung, deswegen hab ich das Ding remapped.
Und ich hab den...
Ich glaube...
Einen von beiden hab ich noch remapped, wenn man ihn lang drückt, dass was anderes passiert.
Da kann man jetzt ein bisschen schneller auf Programme zugreifen.
So und irgendwann hab ich festgestellt, dass die Fernbedienung, die dabei ist, eh nicht so tolle ist.
Und danach hab ich mir einfach eine Fire-TV-Remote gekauft.
Kost nichts, der Scheiß.
Ist gnadenlos billig.
Und eine richtig gute Fernbedienung.
Die kostet nichts, das Zeug.
Viel zu teuer.
Du kriegst den Stick schon für 29 oder für 19 teilweise.
Ach, was auch immer.
Man muss sich einfach einen Fire-TV-Stick kaufen, da ist eine dabei.
Warum ist das eigentlich Amazon.com?
Man muss sich einfach einen Fire-Stick kaufen, dem Angebot am besten.
So und dann kriegt man nämlich die Fernbedienung einfach für 20 Euro plus noch einen Fire-Stick.
Und die Fernbedienung hat alles, was man braucht.
Du hast sogar...
Das ist ja das, was die hier überhaupt nicht hingekriegt haben.
Du hast sogar einen Ein- und Ausschaltknopf.
Den kannst du dann einstellen, dass du theoretisch sogar das Ding runterfahren kannst.
Weil bei dem anderen hast du keinen Button für frei, um Power-Off zu machen.
Hast alles drin, kannst sogar Vorspulenknöpfe.
Perfekt.
Top Fernbedienung.
Also lohnt sich zum Austauschen.
Das ist natürlich besser als das Ding, was dabei ist.
So, weiter aber jetzt.
Kann man dieses alles Bluetooth, ja?
Das funktioniert.
Hä?
Das hab ich nicht gecheckt.
Hab ich nicht gecheckt.
So.
Da haben wir aufgehört.
Ich hab nicht aufgepasst.
Dankeschön für den Subs.
Ich hab's ja ganz ein bisschen.
Face-Gesicht.
Vier Monate.
Äh, was?
Lake...
Rable...
Nein.
Stopp, das hab ich jetzt falsch ausgesprochen.
Aber Dankeschön für die zwei Monate.
In Folge.
Und dann mal schnell gucken, dass ich keinen vergesse.
Ist Stock-Enter-TV-Lounge auf Fire-TV möglich?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ähm, wahrscheinlich.
Du kannst die ganzen...
Die meisten Amazon-Sachen kannst du ziemlich gut deploaten.
Aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab das Firestick da noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ähm...
Streamlabs.
Nicht, dass ich was vergessen hab.
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Wieso sollte man ein Fire-TV kaufen oder so was?
Weil's billig ist.
Und, äh, gut funktioniert.
Na, wenn dein Fernseher das alles kann und du mit der Geschwindigkeit den Funktionen
und den Updates und so von deinem Fernseher zufrieden bist,
wozu sollst du dir ein Firestick kaufen?
Das beantwortet sich ja schon von alleine.
Aber ich kann dir sagen, ich hab mir ein Sony-TV gekauft.
Da ist auch Android-TV drauf.
Also theoretisch mehr oder weniger genau das Gleiche,
was du halt auch beim Shield oder beim Fire-TV kriegst.
Bisschen anders.
Aber, ähm, also bisschen mehr Default.
Aber das Android-TV auf dem Sony-Fernseher ist so extrem träge.
Bist du Mützendräger, ja?
Kappen, Kappen.
Keine Mützen.
Mützen mag ich nicht.
Kappen schon.
Freut mich nicht, wo der Unterschied ist.
Aber Kappen mag ich, Mützen mag ich nicht.
Und bei mir ist das Android-TV auf dem Sony-Fernseher so laggy und so rucklig.
Voll fürn Arsch.
Und gar kein Vergleich zum Shield-TV.
Shield-TV, also der 4K-Stick soll relativ smooth sein.
Aber der Shield-TV ist halt super.
Das Ding ist so weich und schnell von der Bedienung her.
Es gibt nix an.
Es gibt nix.
Ja.
Da krieg ich ein zu wenden.
Jetzt hab ich wieder nicht aufgepasst.
Bam.
Weggesniped.
Ich erkenne überhaupt nix.
Habt ihr...
Habt ihr was erkannt?
Ich hab nix erkannt.
Habt ihr das jetzt gecheckt?
Das war mir zu hoch.
Ah.
Die sprengen sich mit dem Jeep in die Luft und fliegen rum.
Yes.
Exzellent.
Und jetzt schießt er den Small...
Ah.
Jetzt hab ich kapiert.
Und dann fliegen wir dann đi barnh siihen anderen.
Ah.
Ja.
Als ob er sich von der ersten Perspektive anschauen wollte.
Da geht's.
Das sind so geile Sachen in Battlefield.
Die passieren..
Das coole ist.
Was ist L könnt.
Sagt bloß.
Leckt es?
Das können wir gleich kontrollieren ob es leckt.
Vielleicht mal kurz.
Vielleicht mal kurz, vielleicht hat es mal kurz geleckt.
Aber ansonsten läuft es eigentlich ziemlich flüssig.
Das coole war, was ich auch an den alten Battlefile gemacht habe, dass so ein Scheiß funktioniert.
Es funktioniert nicht gut genug.
Kannst du aber bei der Twitch-TV PP geaktivieren?
Wir haben doch PP geaktiviert.
Es funktioniert halt sehr random, was gut ist.
Das heißt, man kann damit die Leute nicht quasi trollen und nerven mit sowas.
Aber dass es ab und zu funktioniert, ist halt geil.
Sind das Kamerads?
Richtig hart geleckt. Echt?
Ah, yes.
Da sind sie wieder.
Da sind sie wieder zugange.
Da schlagen sie wieder zu, Leute.
Da müssen wir jetzt kurz eine Minute warten, bis es wieder funktioniert.
Excellent.
Wo davon?
Ich werde jetzt jedes Mal, wenn es anfängt zu laggen, warten wir eine Minute.
Und machen das Wo-da-vorn-Kack-Emoji-Bild auf.
Aus meiner Teekanne kommt nichts raus.
Oh, ist das heiß.
Ich habe gerade einen Tropfen Tee auf die Schlafanzuchhose geschüttet.
Das Problem ist, die ist dünn.
Das ist direkt aufs Bein.
Ein Zentimeter neben einer Stelle, wo das noch schmerzhafter gewesen wäre.
Warum kommt es überhaupt zu Paketverlust, Überlastung der Knoten?
Das kann an verschiedenen Sachen liegen.
Ich vermute mal, dass das Problem nicht zwischen mir und Unity Media,
beziehungsweise zwischen mir und Wo-da-vorn liegt,
sondern bei den Anbindungen von Wo-da-vorn selbst.
An die unterschiedlichen Netzwerke, an andere Provider und sonst was.
Warum machst du das Kack-Emoji nicht in das Wo-da-vorn-Logo?
Da haben meine Pain-Skills nicht ausgereicht für.
Hi Noob, sieben Monate, huge sub, dankeschön, easy clap.
Vielleicht hast du die Frage schon beantwortet, wirst du dir Valorant angucken?
Vielleicht irgendwann noch mal, wenn man easy keys bekommt oder es gelauncht ist.
So, geht wieder, oder? Hat sich ausgeleckt.
Okay, also was, ich soll die Chat-PoF nochmal zeigen, weil es geleckt hat.
Okay, ich zeige die Chat-PoF nochmal.
Der hat selbst nicht gedacht, dass...
Leckt? Glaub ich nicht. Ihr jebaitet mich. Nichts leckt.
Es leckt überhaupt nicht. Oh, es leckt wieder.
Es leckt wieder. Es leckt wieder.
Meine gute Wo-da-vorn, come on brah, was ist da los?
Warum geht das nicht? Come on Wo-da-vorn, was soll das?
Boomer, alles Boomers.
Die haben keine Ahnung, wozu Deutschland überhaupt Internet braucht.
Sie können ja froh sein, dass es überhaupt funktioniert.
Wer will dann auch schon, dass es zuverlässig funktioniert?
Es leckt immer noch, oder?
Ah ja, ist das nicht schön, wenn es leckt.
Was ist da bei Wo-da-vorn nur los?
Ganz einen kleinen Kacknoobs bei Wo-da-vorn.
Wenn du die Stream-FPS halbierst, verlierst du nur halb so viele Frames.
Exzellent.
Easy, so ist das. Und wenn wir alle ein Auge zumachen, sehen wir nur halb so viele FPS.
Easy.
Ist es fertig laggen? Nee, es leckt immer noch.
Stimmt, ich sollte meine SSIDs endlich ändern.
Da können wir mal gucken, ob es irgendwelche offenen Fragen gibt.
Die kann ich ja beantworten, wenn es leckt.
Es leckt immer noch.
Da dreht man schon durch mit Wo-da-vorn.
Wie? Wo-da-vorn.
Gibt es irgendwelche Fragen, die ich übersehen habe?
Irgendjemand hat gefragt, ob ich mir ein neues Internet beim Anbieter bestellen kann.
Mein Vater meint, es kommt auch auf die Leitung an.
Du kannst dir bei deinem Anbieter nichts bestellen, was bei dir nicht liegt.
Du kannst dir keine Telekom Glasfaser bestellen.
Du kannst dir auch kein Wo-da-vorn bestellen, wenn du kein Kabel hast.
Du musst vorher immer diesen Verfügbarkeitscheck machen und gucken, was Sache ist.
Immer noch nicht den PassiveX.
Kennst du How to land a Space Shuttle? Hab ich doch vorhin schon mal beantwortet.
Was für eine Niedlung würdest du als Gast-System in AVM empfehlen?
Macht eigentlich gar nicht so viel Unterschied, was ich sonst für eine Niedlung empfehlen würde.
Ich benutze Manjaro für alles mittlerweile.
Außer auf dem Server, da benutze ich Ubuntu und auf der Arbeit haben wir CentOS.
Ansonsten würde ich sagen, nimm das, womit du gut klarkommst.
Wenn du kein Hardcore-Hackerman bist und keinen Bock hast, dir einen Manjaro einzurichten,
dann nimmst du entweder ein vorkonfiguriertes oder ein Linux-Mint.
Mint läuft mit XFCE auch ziemlich gut in der AVM-Ware.
Let's place to the NW2 Remastered-Kampagne habe ich jetzt nicht vor.
Wo kann man das denn nachsauen?
Du musst bei den jeweiligen Anbietern auf die Homepage gehen, dann suchst du nach
Verfügbarkeits-Check oder sowas und gibst eine Adresse ein und schaust, was es gibt.
Wieso lag das, weil Vodafone scheiße ist?
Was liegt von der Telekom bei mir im Haus, Kupfer?
Als maximale Antwort vor dem Kiesbohr sieht es aus.
Vielleicht hast du die Frage schon beantwortet, aber das hatten wir ja gerade.
Viel Zeit, dass du in die Schweiz ziehst, ich will nicht in die Schweiz.
Kannst du jedes Mal, wenn es laggt, dieses Kack-Emoji-Bild von Tweeten, jedes Mal,
wenn ich das tweete, jedes Mal, wenn es laggt, werde ich gebannt von Twitter.
Wegen Spam.
Hatten wir schon.
Ich bin gerade im C-Chaos mit Pointers und blicke da nicht ganz durch.
Willkommen im Club, da bist du nicht der einzige, der sowas nicht ganz durchblickt.
Es gibt wenige, die da permanent immer ganz durchblicken, wenn es um Pointer-Magic geht.
Da blickt niemand ganz durch, weil sonst gibt es keine Sicherheitslücken.
Wenn da die Profis durchblicken würden, hätten wir kaum Sicherheitslücken.
Das heißt, die Profis blicken da auch nicht durch.
Lohnt sich das ein Video-Shield noch? Ja.
Habe ich.
Hatten wir auch schon, hatten wir auch schon.
Das gucken wir nachher.
Irgendwie schaffe ich das nicht mit den Chat-Follows mit dem Haus-System.
Du musst die Virtual-Box-Tools installieren. Und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen,
Oracle kümmert sich nicht wirklich gut um.
Wie sieht es euch im Lag aus? Ist es mittlerweile noch...
Ach Gott, der Scheiß laggt ja immer noch. Wo davon? Meine Fresse, ey.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Wie soll man sich da nicht aufregen?
Also, ich finde eh nicht, dass sich Oracle wirklich gut um Virtual-Box kümmert.
Bitrate runter, können wir gleich probieren, ja.
Also ich finde, wie gesagt, Oracle kümmert sich eh nicht gut um Virtual-Box.
Also ich würde vor allem bei Workstation probieren.
Vor allem bei Workstation habe ich viel weniger Probleme als mit Virtual-Box.
Wir machen mal die Bitrate ein bisschen runter, in der Hoffnung, dass es dann...
Wir testen, ob es überhaupt an der Bitrate liegt.
Wir machen mal 2 MBit.
Ich meine, mit 2 MBit können wir nicht ordentlich Videos gucken.
Aber macht anscheinend keinen Unterschied. Hat immer noch geleckt.
5766.
Hast du deinen Wohnervornvertrag schon gekündigt? Nee.
Ich wollte, ich habe gesagt, ich war kurz davor, dass es direkt zu kündigen.
Die Sache ist plus die, das Angebot insgesamt ist halt deutlich besser als bei der Telekom.
Auch von der Geschwindigkeit, die bei mir zur Verfügung steht, ist es deutlich besser.
Also ich habe nicht so wirklich eine gute Alternative zur Wohnervorn.
Das ist mein Problem.
Hätte ich eine gute Alternative, wäre ich schon weg.
Okay, mit 2 MBit leckt es anscheinend nicht.
War ja gerade VPN-Tunnel einrichten. Also je nachdem, wo Vodafone Probleme hat, kann dann VPN sogar was bringen.
Aber dann müsste ich ja den Endpunkt noch bezahlen.
Oder ich hole mir NordVPN. Oder ExpressVPN. Oder, oder, äh...
Was haben wir denn da sonst noch?
ExpressVPN.
Telekom als Mailanschluss und Vodafone als Backup. Ja, so hatte ich das früher.
So hatte ich das früher. Aber ich hatte keine Lust mehr, 2 Internetanschlüsse zu bezahlen.
Ich habe 160 Euro im Monat bezahlt und jetzt bezahle ich nur noch 60 oder so.
Jetzt scheint es zu funktionieren, oder?
So, dann stellen wir die Bitrate mal wieder etwas hoch und schauen, ob es dann...
Weil ich meine, wir können keine Videos gucken mit so einer Kack Bitrate.
Also wir müssen mal mindestens, mindestens 3, 3, 9 machen. Mindestens.
Es ist gerade wieder hochgegangen.
5, 7, 8, 4.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück und es geht jetzt wieder.
Ich stelle mal hoch auf das alte, was ich bisher immer habe.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt mal machen?
Ich will mal gucken, ob es kaputt geht.
Oh, oh, fuck.
Ohje, ohjejeje.
Oh, oh, oh.
Ne, ne, ne.
Cack.
Keine gute Idee.
Es hat nicht gut funktioniert.
Okay, wir probieren jetzt mal, ob es weitergeht.
Leute, sagt mir, wenn es...
Na, es leckt immer noch.
Meine Fresse, Vodafone.
Was ist denn los mit euch?
Das ist jetzt so nur das Symptom, was wir hier haben und nicht das Problem.
Das eigentliche Problem ist, dass der Internetausbau in Deutschland scheiße ist.
Und die Infrastruktur scheiße ist.
Wenn man nämlich seine ganze Sache schon so auslegt...
Oh Gott, ey, meine Güte.
Wenn man seine ganze Sache schon so auslegt, dass sie unter normalen Bedingungen schon Oberkante, Unterlippe läuft,
und jetzt so was dazukommt, wie das eben viele Leute zu Hause sind und auch noch Sonntag ist,
dann ist es natürlich komplett im Arsch.
Ich brauche einen dritten Power-Upload.
Ah, yes.
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass es immer noch leckt, auch mit 2 MBit?
Leute, wir können keine Videos gucken mit der Bitrate.
Mit der Bitrate sieht, pass mal auf, ey, wenn ich das Video jetzt anmache, sieht mega beschissen aus auf 2 MBit.
Da erkennst du überhaupt nichts.
Ups, nicht das Video.
Das da, du erkennst überhaupt nichts, wenn ich das anmache.
Das sieht scheiße aus mit 2 MBit.
Guckt euch das mal an.
MonkaX, das sieht nicht gut aus, das sieht verpixelt aus wie Sau.
Geht das?
Okay, wenn das geht, dann gucken wir jetzt 10 Minuten so, in der Hoffnung, dass das Geleger weggeht,
und jetzt müssen wir uns nochmal den Jeep angucken, weil das habe ich immer noch nicht richtig gecheckt, Alter.
Besser als nichts, ja.
Dann machen wir jetzt eine Sache, dass die Leute sich nicht wundern, warum die Quali so schlecht ist.
Vodafone.
Was ist denn Vodafone Flame?
Ah, das ist da, wo ich Vodafone Flame muss, weil du nur Mann und Frau auswählen konntest, ja.
Exellent.
Wo habe ich denn mein Vodafone Bild?
Hier, Vodafone PNG.
Das müssen wir mal hier einblenden.
Image.
Ah, yes, excellent image.
Und dann ist das wo auf dem Desktop?
Äh, Moment mal, nicht so groß, nee, nee.
Vodafone, nicht so groß.
Aber ich lasse das jetzt permanent eingeblendet,
dass die Leute wissen, warum das Scheiß nicht richtig funktioniert.
Super Desktop nur Memebildchen.
Ja, Prioritäten.
Mit welchem Programm rennst du deine Videos?
Mit FFmpeg.
Aber mit so einer Latte Option, die kann ich dir jetzt nicht aus dem Kopf sagen.
So, jetzt aber, Battlefield 4 Plays.
Gut, ja, er freut sich.
Und die Viper kann sehr nervig sein.
Ja, das haben wir schon gehört.
Schreckt.
Wow.
What?
Hä?
Wie hat er den dann gekillt?
Bombe gedroppt.
Ah, der ist in die Bombe geflogen.
Ja.
Danny, die drei Monate, Dankeschön.
Oh, das Sound ist Assung, das liegt nicht an mir.
Der Clip ist Assung.
Mein Gott, ist das pixelig mit dieser Kackbitrate.
Guckt euch mal an, wie das pixelt.
Die Bitrate ist jenseits von gut und böse.
Das pixelt wie Sau, ich sehe es auf meiner Vorschau.
Gerade auch Metro mit den vielen Details.
DrEvilKookie, vier Monate, EasyClap-Subscriber.
Oh, die werden schon weggesprayed.
Und die Kackloops treffen wieder nichts.
Warthorn habe ich nicht angefasst.
Die Range von der Shotgun wieder.
Und die Gegner, mein Güte, sind das manchmal PP-Gegner.
Ui.
Sag mal, mal hier, die Militär-Profis unter euch.
So viel kannst du doch mit einem echten Flieger, mit einem echten Jet überhaupt nicht ballern, oder?
Da hast du doch nur ganz wenig Munition dabei für deine Bordkanone.
Da kannst du nicht drei Minuten rum ballern, oder?
Ich will jetzt nicht mit der Geschichte ankommen, Battlefield und Realität.
Ist mir nur gerade eingefallen.
Und jetzt?
Hä?
Moment, das habe ich nicht gecheckt.
Das war zu schnell für mich.
Vor allem, wie er explodiert mit der Armbrust.
Das ist ja nice.
Das ist cool, das war ein echt cooler Clip.
Das ist gut schmeckt.
Beste Waffe.
Glaub mir, mit der Waffe habe ich die meiste Spielzeit in dem Game.
Aber auch nur, weil ich nicht M16 Noob sein wollte, aber ähnliche Noob-Waffe verwenden.
Oh, ja, was war denn das?
Moment, hat er den doch erwischt?
Hat er den doch erwischt?
Dude.
Ist aber ein nicer Streak, den er da am Start hat.
Was ist an dem Clip jetzt cool?
Na ja, man hat davon abgesehen, dass er 30 Leute killt oder so.
Jetzt killt er 30 Leute.
So einen Streak hast du jetzt auch nicht so oft.
Und er macht noch Legehenne.
Leute, der Chat ist mittlerweile eins, muss ich sagen.
Ich merke das öfters, dass der Chat und das, was ich sage, schon so auf einer Wellenlänge manchmal ist.
In dem Moment, wo ich sage, und er macht Legehenne, gucke ich in den Chat und in der gleichen Sekunde schreiben die Leute Legehenne.
So geil.
Ihr konntet das noch gar nicht gehört haben.
Oh, der war gut.
Dass er dem noch voll in den Kopf getroffen hat.
Ich glaube, es ist normaler Scope Speed.
Da werden sie weggesprayt.
Schautraffi ist hier der beste.
Streck den Kopf um die Ecke.
Da steht er und checkt nix.
Ich habe nicht viel Team Deathmatch gespielt, aber was das Gute an Team Deathmatch in Battlefield 3 war, es gab wenig Bullshit.
Es gab keine Killstreaks, keine across the map Genoob-Tube, One-Man-Army-Danger-Klaus.
Es war einfach in your face Shooter-Geballer.
Die Gran-Camper gibt es auch.
Die Gran-Camper, ja.
Es war nicht alles perfekt, es war schon gut.
Anzeige ist raus.
Er hat den Defi angetäuscht.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Er wird Revived.
Hat er es geleckt?
Bei mir in der Vorschau hat es gerade geleckt.
Oder war das meine Vorschau, die geleckt hat?
Ist das Hardline?
An Play-Mäßig war Hardline gar nicht schlecht, da hat mir Hardline eigentlich gefallen.
Was ich an Hardline halt doof fand, ist, dass kaum ein Spielmodus dabei war, der mir gefallen hat.
Hätten die mal ordentlich einen Rush gebaut?
Echt?
Hardline bekommt mehr Spieler?
Was ist mit denen denn los?
Da hätte ich mich erst mal hinter den Felsen gelegt, wenn ich die Schüsse vor dem Heli gesehen hätte.
Zum Glück trifft der Heli nicht richtig.
Collateral auf den Heli, das ist natürlich nice.
Wir gucken uns jetzt wirklich das MW2-Review an.
Mich würde echt interessieren, ob man das überhaupt erkennt.
Ich habe ein paar Tweets gesehen auf Twitter, wo Leute gepostet haben, wie sie angefangen haben zu spielen.
Es ist Vodafone, ich kann nichts dagegen machen.
Ich habe nicht so viel Remastered erkannt.
Bei dem ganzen Gepixel werden wir wahrscheinlich auch nichts erkennen.
Das ist halt für ein Arsch, was soll ich machen?
Was soll ich machen, wenn das sogar mit 2 MB druckelt?
Da kann man es eigentlich komplett vergessen.
Wenn ich jetzt an Unity Media schreibe, sagt die, schick uns doch mal bitte deine Kundennummer per PN
und das nächste was dann kommt ist, die Modemwerte sehen aber überhaupt nicht gut aus.
Immer der gleiche Scheiß, ihr Dummschwätzer.
Vodafone, meine Fresse, Kackvereine.
Dann guckt ihr das Video vielleicht später an.
Wir gucken mal das Corona Update.
Sechste Training, 3 Millionen auf ETF.
Das hat ja mehr als mein Gartenstellsvideo.
Und es gibt nicht viele Videos, die mehr als mein Gartenstellsvideo haben.
Schauen wir mal.
Exzellenz-Statistik.
Das ist morgen nicht vorbei, ist es klar.
Und das wird in nächster Zeit nicht sein.
Es dauert ewig.
Arbeitest du dich auch kaputt? Nee, genauso wie vorher.
Wie lange müssen wir also noch durchhalten?
Das ist noch zu früh zu sagen.
Man kann das, ich gehe mal davon aus, sie zeigt sowas auch.
Gitterprojekt.
Was heißt Prognose auf Englisch?
Ich habe letztens ein cooles Gitterprojekt gefunden, was genau solche Sachen drin hat.
Quasi voraussagen, wie es ablaufen könnte, wo man dann auch ein bisschen drin rumbasteln konnte.
Prediction, ja genau.
Nee, das ist es nicht.
Muss ich mal nachher gucken, das war eigentlich ganz praktisch.
Da hat sich einer die Mühe gemacht und quasi schon ein bisschen QuickMuffs erstellt.
Dann sehen wir ja, über ein paar Dinge sollten wir jetzt schon ausführlich sprechen.
Und auch Zahlen anschauen, die man vielleicht nicht sehen möchte.
Ist laut genug? Müsste eigentlich.
Holt euch einen Tee, macht es euch gemütlich, denn so viel vorweg, wir brauchen Geduld.
Es ist natürlich richtig, dass wir gerade auf die Daten über die Wirksamkeit unserer aktuellen Maßnahmen warten.
Die haben wir erst in zwei, drei Wochen.
Darüber will ich hier auch nicht spekulieren.
Ich meine, es ist ja auch richtig und wichtig, im Nebel auf Sicht zu fahren.
Aber wir wollen doch trotzdem ungefähr wissen, wie lang die Straße sein wird, oder?
Und die Sache ist, die über die Länge der Straße wissen wir jetzt schon ziemlich gut Bescheid.
Und bei all der Berichterstattung über die Corona-Krise ist genau das ein Punkt, über den meiner Meinung nach zu wenig diskutiert.
Ja, da hat sie recht.
Um das alles zu verstehen, kurz vorweg ein paar Basics zu all den beiden Epidemen.
Da dreht sich so gut wie nichts drum.
So nach dem Motto Ausblinken mäßig, was kommt auf einen zu?
Kannst du den Ticken lauter machen? Ja, kann ich machen.
Da gibt es wirklich ziemlich wenig zu.
Die Phasen der Epidemiebekämpfung.
Phase eins, Containment.
Unter Containment verstehen Epidemiologen Eindämmung.
Also idealerweise versucht man, die Krankheit im Keim zu ersticken.
So solchen Eindämmungsmaßnahmen gehören.
Kranke isolieren, Kontakte nachverfolgen, isolieren, auf das Virus testen, also Überblick halten.
Isolieren hat bei uns ja nicht so gut funktioniert.
Wir haben uns lieber gedacht, ach scheiß drauf, lass die Leute Fasching feiern.
Die Verbreitung verhindern.
Es kann aber schnell mal sowas passieren, wie z.B. in Heinsberg, also ein infiziertes Paar feiert mit 300 weiteren Karneval.
Und dann kommt man schon kaum hinterher.
Das habe ich null verstanden, ey.
Italien war schon am Abkacken.
Und bei uns hat man sich gedacht, ach ja, lass mal eine Runde Fasching machen.
Folgung der Kontakte, den Verwaltungsapparat.
Enter Phase 2, Mitigation.
Am besten zu übersetzen mit Schadensbegrenzung.
Wenn wir nicht mehr nachvollziehen können, wer jetzt alles infiziert ist, klappt jetzt diese gezielte Isolierung nicht mehr.
Deswegen müssen wir alle mitmachen, also Abstand halten, Homeoffice, Veranstaltungen absagen usw. Ihr kennt es.
In dieser Phase hat man den Versuch einer Eindämmung erst mal aufgegeben.
Aber man will jetzt wenigstens die Ausbreitung verlangsamen.
Warum das so wichtig ist, dürfte inzwischen bei jedem angekommen sein.
Über flatten the curve wurde in letzter Zeit so viel gesprochen, dass das Grundprinzip von Mitigation dem meisten klar sein sollte.
Aber dieses rein qualitative Verständnis kann trügerisch wirken.
Also noch mal kurze Wiederholung.
Je langsamer die Epidemie verläuft, desto weniger Menschen sind gleichzeitig infiziert.
Und desto weniger Menschen brauchen gleichzeitig medizinische Behandlung.
So verhindern wir, dass unser Gesundheitssystem...
Aber umso länger dauert es, bis die Leute immer alle durch sind.
... in Italien, Spanien oder New York mit Schrecken beobachten.
Wenn die Intensivstationen nicht mehr genug Betten für alle Patienten haben,
dann müssen schreckliche Entscheidungen über Leben und Tod getroffen werden.
Das darf nicht passieren.
Das Problem ist jetzt, das gerade bei vielen folgende Eindruck entsteht.
Der Lockdown ist heftig, aber wir geben jetzt gerade auch alles.
Und hoffentlich kriegen wir damit die Kurve so flach,
dass wir vielleicht nach Ostern, vielleicht ein bisschen später
das Ganze einigermaßen glimpflich hinter uns gebracht haben.
Diese Vorstellung ist leider realitätsferne Fantasie.
Warum das so ist, verstehen wir, wenn wir uns konkrete Zahlen anschauen.
Da muss ich ehrlich sagen, ich hab mir noch keine...
Ihr Video leckt wundervoll. Guck oben links in die Ecke.
Ich kann nichts dagegen machen gerade.
Das ist auch so eine Sache.
Ich hab mir jetzt noch keine Statistik genau angeguckt.
Aber ich denk mal, das kommt gleich.
Ich fand das eh schon die ganze Zeit enorm kurzfristig,
wie die Leute gedacht haben, so irgendwie, ja,
in zwei Wochen gucken wir dann mal weiter.
Und ja, dann ist es dann nach Ostern.
Ach ja, das dauert noch ewig, bis das vorbei ist.
Das ist nicht eine Sache von drei, vier Wochen oder einem Monat.
Oh.
Alle Maßnahmen, die wir jetzt so die letzten Wochen mitbekommen haben,
Aufruf zum Händewaschen, über Kontaktverfolgung bis zum Lockdown,
dienen dazu, die Reproduktionszahl zu senken.
YouTube, acht Monate, danke schön.
Grafisch gesprochen, je kleiner die Reproduktionszahl,
desto flacher die Kurve.
Wie flach ist nun flach genug?
Diese Frage wird beantwortet in der Stellungnahme
der Deutschen Gesellschaft für Epidemiologie
zur Ausbreitung des neuen Coronavirus.
Hier findet man Modellierungen für verschiedene Szenarien.
Diese Modellierungen sind wohlgemerkt keine Voraussagen.
Jede Epidemie ist ein Einzelfall.
Deswegen arbeiten ja gerade auch Forscher mit Hochdruck daran,
dieses neue Virus besser zu verstehen.
Aber Modellierungen können verschiedene denkbare Szenarien durchrechnen,
in deren Rahmen sich der zukünftige Verlauf bewegen könnte.
Und anhand dieser Szenarien können wir ableiten,
welche Maßnahmen den Verlauf in welcher Form beeinflussen können.
Wie würde nun die effektive Reproduktionszahl
den Verlauf beeinflussen?
Oder konkreter gesagt, wie stark müssen wir die Reproduktionszahl senken,
damit die Kurve hinreichend flach wird?
Also so flach, dass unser Gesundheitssystem es handeln kann.
Dazu brauchen wir erst mal eine Vorstellung davon,
wie groß die Kapazitäten unseres Gesundheitssystems in Deutschland sind.
Tja, das ist auch so ein Punkt, da könnte ich mich wahrscheinlich,
mache ich jetzt nicht, eine halbe Stunde darüber auslassen,
dass lustigerweise gerade jetzt wieder mal,
so abgegangen wird so nach dem Motto,
ja, wir huldigen allen Pflegekräften und Ärzten und sonst was.
Und ich verstehe mich, die haben das ohne Wenn und Aber verdient.
Aber was man nicht vergessen darf,
die Entscheidungen, die die letzten, sagen wir mal, 10 Jahre
oder vielleicht 15 Jahre getroffen wurden, haben halt dazu geführt,
dass unser Gesundheitssystem zu was geworden ist,
was sich weniger an Patienten und Kranken orientiert,
als eher, wie kann ich maximal Gewinn aus einem Einzelpatient rausholen?
Und das ist jetzt halt was, das kommt uns da nicht zugute.
Also Beatmungsgeräte, Schutzkleidung für das Personal,
natürlich auch das Personal an sich.
Aber nehmen wir mal einen limitierenden Faktor,
mit dem wir das Ganze durchrechnen können,
nämlich die Anzahl der Betten auf den Intensivstationen,
auf die die schweren Corona-Verläufe angewiesen sind.
In Deutschland gibt es derzeit rund 30.000 intensivmedizinische Betten.
Die sind aber nicht alle frei.
Bei allen laufenden Bemühungen, die Kapazitäten aufzustocken,
sind natürlich viele dieser Betten besetzt von Nicht-Corona-Patienten.
Aber nehmen wir für unsere Betrachtung jetzt einfach mal an,
also wir hätten 30.000 freie Betten.
Okay, wie viele Menschen werden jetzt wegen Covid-19
ein Bett auf einer Intensivstation brauchen?
Knärbeer, wie fühlst du dich eigentlich als Overwatch League-Supporter auf Twitch?
Wenn die jetzt auf YouTube sind.
Und wie lange muss man sie dort behandeln?
Die deutsche Gesellschaft für Epidemiologie schätzt,
dass zwei bis sechs Prozent der Corona-Infizierten ein Intensivbett brauchen.
Die Liegedauer ist verhältnismäßig lang, nämlich 10 bis 20 Tage,
also je nach Patient.
Hier wurden jetzt neun verschiedene Szenarien modelliert.
Mit zwei, vier oder sechs Prozent intensivpflichtigen Patienten
und mit 10, 15 oder 20 Tagen Liegedauer.
Schauen wir uns zuerst das Best-Case...
Ich persönlich hoffe ja drauf.
Ich bin ja jetzt ein paar Wochen lang in Frankfurt noch zur Arbeit gefahren,
als dieser Kram schon am Start war.
Ich hoffe ja persönlich, dass ich es schon hatte und nicht gemerkt habe.
Das wäre das beste Szenario für mich, weil dann könnte ich ihn immer kriegen.
Szenarien, in denen nur zwei Prozent der Erkrankten
eine Intensivbehandlung brauchen, und zwar alle nur für 10 Tage.
In diesem Szenario würde man bei einer Reproduktionszahl von 1,5,
also das ist die grüne Kurve,
die Kapazitäten über einen langen Zeitraum komplett springen.
Erst bei einer Reproduktionszahl von 1,25.
Nähern wir uns zwar der 30.000 Bettengrenze,
würden sie zu Peak-Zeiten aber immer noch springen.
Und wenn sie jetzt nicht zwei, sondern vier Prozent sind,
dann sind es halt direkt doppelt so viele Patienten, die ein Bett brauchen.
Bei den meisten dieser Szenarien,
dann muss die Reproduktionszahl auf 1,1
oder sehr nah an 1,1 runtergedrückt werden,
um eine Überbelastung der Intensivstation zu vermeiden.
Und im Worst-Case-Szenario haben wir selbst bei einer Reproduktionszahl von 1,1
zu Peak-Zeiten zehntausende Menschen täglich,
die nicht behandelt werden können.
Zusammengefasst, um unser Gesundheitssystem nicht zu überlasten,
brauchen wir Maßnahmen, welche die effektive Reproduktionszahl
auf einen Bereich zwischen 1,25 und 1,1 senken.
Ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
dass das nur mit ordentlicher Kontaktreduktion möglich ist.
Aber jetzt schaut mal auf die Zeitachse.
Bei diesen strengen Maßnahmen wäre die Epidemie erst nach einem Jahr vorbei.
Beziehungsweise in den meisten Fällen noch länger.
Die flachste Kurve, die blühe, die ist hier abgeschnitten.
Das klingt vollkommen nachvollziehbar.
Unterm Strich heißt das.
Wie gesagt, ich habe mir vorher keine Statistik in der Richtung angeschaut,
aber es klingt vollkommen logisch.
Du kannst ja nicht alles haben.
Du kannst die Überlastung der Krankenhäuser nicht haben wollen.
Und gleichzeitig möglichst schnell alle Leute durch.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Es sei denn, du hättest 80 Millionen Krankenhausplätze,
die wir halt nicht haben. Wo soll die herkommen?
Systems zu vermeiden, müssen wir strenge Maßnahmen
für ein bis zwei Jahre lang aufrechterhalten.
Und das geht nicht.
Wir sehen ja jetzt schon, welche immense Schäden
für die Volkswirtschaft zu erwarten sind.
Da hängen Existenzen und damit auch wieder Menschenleben dran.
Und auch welche allgemein gesellschaftlichen,
auch psychologischen Folgen das hätte langfristig.
Das können wir derzeit...
Gut, das stimmt nicht. 80 Millionen brauchst du nicht.
Du brauchst 5 Prozent oder so, ein bisschen plus minus.
Aber du bräuchst trotzdem irgendwie 2, 3 Millionen Krankenhausplätze.
Und die haben wir nicht. Wo soll die herkommen?
Wie viel hat es am Anfang gesagt? 30.000?
Da ist 30.000 zu 3 Millionen.
Ist schon ein bisschen kleiner Unterschied dazwischen.
Kann ich fassen. Ich weiß, dass bei diesen Modellierungen
nicht nur Annahmen, sondern auch Vereinfachungen gemacht wurden.
Und ich weiß auch, dass es noch Parameter gibt über Covid-19,
die wir jetzt noch nicht kennen, die aber einen wesentlichen Einfluss haben.
Wie zum Beispiel, was jetzt eigentlich mit den sehr schwach
oder sogar asymptomatischen Verläufen ist.
Aber allein diese Größenordnung,
wenn die Größenordnung nicht völlig daneben ist,
dann ist flatten the curve bis zur Herrenimmunität nicht durchhaltbar.
Und ist diese Stellungnahme nicht brandneu?
Sie wurde am Tag von Merkels Ansprache veröffentlicht
und ein paar Tage später aktualisiert.
Aber wenn ich jetzt heute in die Medienberichte schaue,
dann wird immer noch der Eindruck vermittelt,
als sei flatten the curve nach wie vor der Masterplan.
Und wie kann das sein, wenn das offenbar so nicht aufgehen wird?
Weil die auch wissen, dass die Leute überhaupt keinen Plan haben
und wenn du ihnen was erzählst, sie es nicht checken.
Deswegen erzählen sie dir im Fernsehen und sonst wo
die einfachstmöglichste Variante,
die dafür sorgt, dass die Leute die Klappe halten.
Guck mal, wie unfähig die meisten Leute schon sind, im Internet Klopapier zu bestellen.
Das ist so das Brain-Niveau, von dem wir reden.
Leute, die nicht in der Lage sind,
im Internet sich eine Packung Klopapier zu bestellen.
Und denen will man jetzt irgendwas Komplettes erklären.
Das klappt im Leben nicht.
Professor Raphael Mikolajczyk geredet, der die Stellungnahme mit verfasst hat.
Um mich zu versichern, dass wir nicht etwas Grundlegendes missverstanden haben,
vielen Dank an dieser Stelle für das aufschlussreiche Hintergrundgespräch.
Hintergrundgespräch?
Das heißt, sie hat aufgenommen, sie hat im Hintergrund gesprochen, oder was?
Ignore on.
Werden wir jetzt schon klar, was gemeint ist.
Manche Leute verstehen ja immer nicht, wenn man mal einen Scherz macht.
Das zu interpretieren. Die Antwort auf die Frage,
wie stark müssen wir die Reproduktionszahl senken,
damit die Kurve hinreichend flach wird, lautet,
die Reproduktionszahl muss auf unter 1 gesenkt werden.
Den abflachen alleine würde zu lange dauern. Wir müssen die Kurve stoppen.
Kurz und schmerzhaft zurück zum Start.
Die Fallzahl muss so klein werden,
dass unsere Gesundheitsämter wieder dazu in der Lage sind,
alle Fälle zu überschauen und zu verfolgen.
Da hab ich noch gar nicht dran gedacht.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich gute Taktik.
Wenn man das nicht nur versucht einzudämmen,
sondern wenn man schafft, dass es rückläufig ist,
aber die Sache ist bloß die,
ob das funktioniert, ist auch die Frage.
Dann schaffst du es erstens nicht, dass die Leute es bekommen
und irgendwann mal vielleicht immun dagegen sind,
was eh schwierig ist, weil es ewig dauert.
Auf der anderen Seite einmal irgendwie verkackt,
einmal an irgendeiner Veranstaltung,
irgendeinem Typ mit Corona am Start.
Das Ganze geht von vorne los.
Wann können wir wieder effektiv Kranke isolieren,
Kontakte verfolgen, Kontaktketten brechen, die Krankheit eindämmen?
Das bedeutet, wenn die Infektionszahlen nicht mehr nur langsamer steigen,
sondern wirklich abnehmen,
dann kommen wir irgendwann wieder zu einem Punkt,
wo wir mit unseren Maßnahmen wieder bei Phase 1 Containment sind.
Dann würde für viele Menschen wieder so etwas wie Normalität zurückkehren,
denn dann wären die strengen Maßnahmen wieder nur gezielt
auf die Erkrankten und ihre Kontaktpersonen konzentriert.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was sie mit Normalität haben.
Für mich ist das normal.
Ich sitze einfach vor meinem Computer den ganzen Tag
und habe keinerlei Kontakt zu meiner Umwelt.
Das ist... Wo ist der Unterschied? Verstehe ich nicht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die alle haben.
Nur ist der Weg zurück zu Phase 1 natürlich nur mit strengen Maßnahmen für alle machbar.
Denn noch mal, ein Infizierter muss weniger als einen weiteren anstecken,
damit das aufgeht.
Wie schnell hat man zwei Personen angesteckt?
Vor allem, wenn man vielleicht nicht darauf achtet,
weil man eher milde Symptome hat.
Oder wenn irgendwo jemand zehn weitere Menschen ansteckt bei einer Veranstaltung,
dann dürfen neun andere niemanden mehr anstecken.
Reichen denn nun unsere aktuellen Maßnahmen aus,
um die Reproduktionszahl so stark zu senken?
Eben auf diese Einschätzung warten wir ja gerade.
Aber so viel kann man schon mal sagen.
Dass dieser Lockdown beschlossen wurde, ist definitiv angemessen und richtig.
Also wenn wir wirklich zu Phase 1 zurück wollen,
dann ist das, was wir gerade machen, auf keinen Fall übertrieben oder unnötig streng.
Denn wir können jetzt schon sagen, dass wir...
Ich muss eine Sache sagen.
Ein Vorteil wird das Ganze haben.
Ganz viele Unternehmen, die bisher quasi aus reinen Boomer-Führungskräften
und Leute ohne IT-Ahnung bestanden,
müssen jetzt alles, wenn sie überleben wollen, zwangsdigitalisieren.
Die haben gar keine andere Chance.
Also sprich, Homeoffice wird immer weiter verbreitet werden,
auch in Zukunft dadurch.
Die technischen Infrastruktursachen werden bei vielen Unternehmen
ausgebaut werden müssen, weil sonst können sie sich überleben.
Das heißt, durch Corona schaffen wir in vielen Bereichen
tatsächlich mal den Sprung ins Jahr 2020,
was andere Länder schon besser nix von Pause zu drücken.
Schaffen wir es echt, im Jahr 2020 anzukommen.
Gerade nur, dass unser Internetinfrastrukturausbau
so scheiße gelaufen ist die letzten Jahre und es nicht mitmacht.
Ziemlich weit entfernt sind von einer Fallzahl, die niedrig genug ist.
Denken wir das mal durch.
Im Netz gibt es einige Online-Simulationen von Epidemien,
mit denen man ja rumspielen kann.
Jetzt mal nur zur Veranschaulichung. Der ist ganz gut.
Wir können jetzt hier die Parameter, die Ansteckung,
Hospitalisierungsrat und so weiter so einstellen,
wie die Deutsche Gesellschaft für Epidemiologie
in ihren Simulationen gemacht hat.
Und dann schauen, wie lange es dauern wird,
bis wir wieder zu Containment übergehen können.
Jetzt muss ich hier eine Annahme treffen,
nämlich wie tief die Fallzahl sinken muss,
also ab welcher Fallzahl Containment wieder möglich wäre.
Die wirkliche Zahl hängt zum Beispiel ganz stark ab
von unseren Testkapazitäten, davon wie viele Ressourcen
und Personal wir noch in die Behörden stecken können,
wo die Infrastruktur ist und so weiter.
Aber orientieren wir uns mal an den Tag, an den Jens Spahn sagte,
dass man Veranstaltungen mit mehr als 1000 Menschen absagen sollte.
Denn spätestens dann gab es offenbar ein Problem
mit der Nachverfolgung der Fälle.
An diesem Tag gab es in Deutschland ungefähr 1000 Fälle.
Nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal an.
1000 wäre jetzt die Fallzahl, die noch handlebar wäre.
Das hat das Sebaro bezahlt.
Ich habe vom Sebaro noch nichts gehört, aber ich bezahle das.
Wir haben heute ca. 70.000 Fälle.
Jetzt können wir hier einstellen, dass wir ab dem Tag,
wo die Epidemie 70.000 Fälle hat,
die Reproduktionszahl von 2 auf 0,5 runterdrücken.
Reproduktionszahl 0,5, das ist volle Kanone.
Das ist Wuhan-style Lockdown, so muss man sich das vorstellen.
Und unter diesen Annahmen würde es 56 Tage dauern,
bis wir wieder weniger als 1000 Fälle hätten.
Also fast 2 Monate. Das sollte jetzt natürlich keine Prognose sein,
sondern nur ein Beispielsszenario, um ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen,
wie lange das noch dauern könnte.
Und nur damit, dass niemand falsch versteht,
wenn wir es schaffen, mit harten Maßnahmen zurück zu Phase 1 zu kommen,
ist damit ja die Epidemie noch nicht vorbei.
Das kann überhaupt nicht vorbeigehen, solange wir 5G haben.
Solange wir 5G haben, wird Corona nie vorbeigehen.
Wir sind lediglich in einem Zustand, in dem sowohl unser Gesundheitssystem
als auch unsere Wirtschaft funktionieren können.
Also in einem Zustand, in dem wir so lange ausharren können,
bis die Epidemie vorbei ist.
Kleiner Einschub, es gibt noch ein paar unbekannte Eigenschaften des Virus,
die uns vielleicht schneller ans Ziel bringen könnten.
Zum Beispiel eine Saisonalität, das heißt, dass das Virus im Sommer
weniger ansteckend sein könnte.
Oder dass doch ein Teil der Bevölkerung
eine gewisse Immunität gegen dieses Virus haben könnte.
Dazu gibt es Modellierungen vom Robert-Korr-Institut.
Die haben wir euch mit einer kurzen Einordnung in die Videobeschreibung gepackt.
Aber an der Strategie an sich würde das auch nichts ändern.
Es wäre auf jeden Fall falsch, aus einer unbestätigten Hoffnung heraus
Maßnahmen zu lockern, denn so oder so gilt,
je schneller wir in Phase 1 zurück sind, desto besser.
Das klingt jetzt nach ganz schön harter Arbeit,
nur um dahin wieder zurückzukommen, wo wir schon vor einem Monat waren.
Aber ganz wichtig, wir gehen nicht einfach nur einen Schritt zurück.
Beim zweiten Mal wird alles besser.
Die Containment-Phase am Anfang einer Epidemie
steht unter folgendem Dilemma.
Je früher man Maßnahmen greift, desto effektiver ist es.
Aber da eine Epidemie anfangs natürlich nicht so schlimm ist,
wird die Bedrohung oft zu spät erkannt.
Auch hierzulande wurde Corona anfangs von vielen Menschen nicht ernst genommen.
Und politische Entscheidungsträger sind ja nur das eine.
Auch ohne Akzeptanz in der Bevölkerung kann man
strenge Maßnahmen wie zum Beispiel Karneval-Absagen
in einer Demokratie kaum durchsetzen.
Aber wenn wir jetzt wieder zurück...
Ja, weil die Leute dumm sind.
... ins Containment kommen, dann wissen wir, wie der Aase läuft.
Wir sind inzwischen auch alle Profis im Händewaschen
und in Ellenbogen husten und Abstand halten
und basteln sogar gerade an zusätzlichen Maßnahmen
wie selbstgenähte Gesichtsmasken.
Auch unser Gesundheitssystem und die Forschung sind jetzt natürlich...
Es wäre hier nicht auszudenken, nahezu ähm...
Ja, Weltuntergang wäre fast schon ausgefallen.
Gerade werden Testkapazitäten hochgefahren,
die Behörden werden mit mehr Manpower ausgestattet und so weiter.
Also, nicht falsch verstehen.
Ich finde, Deutschland hat durchaus vernünftig auf die Corona-Krise reagiert.
Haben wir auch. Bis sie spät.
Aber wenn wir jetzt fase eins nochmal wiederholen würden,
dann würden wir an allen möglichen Ecken und Enden
die Sache deutlich besser machen.
Einfach nur, weil wir jetzt vieles wissen, was wir vorher nicht wussten.
Nur sollten wir uns klar machen,
wir arbeiten auf eine Lockerung der Maßnahmen
und einen Rückgewinn von Normalität hin.
Aber ganz ohne Verzicht werden wir lange Zeit nicht auskommen.
Dazu gehört vermeidbare Menschenansammlungen.
Also Konzerte, gefüllte Fußballstadien, dichtgepackte Reitenstrecke.
Bin ich froh, dass ich mir kein Iron Maiden-Ticket gekauft habe
für im Juni in Köln.
Hatten wir eigentlich vorher, wollten wir eigentlich hin.
Aber wir haben es jetzt glücklicherweise nicht gemacht
und das findet auch garantiert nicht statt.
Referenzen, dieses Jahr vergesst es.
Ich weiß Boomer-Musik.
Das wäre auch in der Containment-Phase zu riskant.
Mit nur einem Ausbruch könnten wir uns unsere ganzen Bemühungen
wieder kaputt machen.
Ja, selbst Apres Ski in der kommenden Wintersaison, dafür sehe ich schwarz.
Denn eine Timeline habe ich noch für euch.
Wann endet diese Epidemie?
Im Prinzip habe ich das am Anfang schon gesagt.
Die Gamescom kann ich mir vorstellen.
Natürlicherweise ist die Epidemie erst dann vorbei,
wenn Herdenimmunität erreicht ist.
Aber das ist nur Theorie.
In der Praxis können wir natürliche Herdenimmunität quasi vergessen.
Es gibt kein Szenario, bei dem wir eine Herdenimmunität
von 60 bis 70 Prozent erreichen könnten,
ohne dass dabei unvorstellbare Schäden entstehen.
Entweder würden wir die Kapazitäten unseres Gesundheitssystems sprengen,
da würden erschreckend viele Menschen sterben.
Oder wir würden diese Herdenimmunität
unterhalb der Kapazität unseres Gesundheitssystems verfolgen.
Aber das würde so lange dauern,
dass es wirtschaftlich und gesellschaftlich nicht ertragbar wäre.
Daraus kann ich nur eins schließen,
nämlich diese Epidemie wird erst mit einem Impfstoff enden.
Theoretisch auch mit einem Medikament,
das aber auch die Intensivbehandlung weitgehend ersetzen müsste,
was leider unwahrscheinlich ist.
Das heißt, bis zum Impfstoff müssen wir durchhalten.
Und die Entwicklung braucht Zeit.
Also sportliche Schätzungen sprechen hier von Frühjahr 2021.
Und damit wir das so lange mit möglichst wenig Schäden durchhalten,
müssen wir jetzt mit harten Maßnahmen
möglichst schnell zurück zum Containment-Modus,
in dem wir dann bei relativer Normalität ausharren können.
Ich weiß, dass vieles in diesem Video euch wahrscheinlich
entmutigt hat.
Ich sehe das so.
Alles wie immer.
Ich habe lieber einen konkreten Ausweg vor Augen,
auch wenn er schwer ist, als immer nur mit
wir müssen mal schauen im Ungewissen.
Also TH Assassin, ganz so einfach ist das ja auch nicht.
Ich meine, du willst auch in die Stadt gehen,
vielleicht mal im Supermarkt was einkaufen.
Du willst vielleicht auch arbeiten gehen und Geld verdienen.
Du willst vielleicht auch ein paar Sachen auf Amazon kaufen
oder sonst was.
Also ganz auf die Wirtschaft scheißen kannst du ja auch nicht.
Da hängt ja für dich auch einiges dran.
Alten zu werden.
Wenn wir das Ziel kennen, können wir natürlich auch besser zielen.
Also wir können jetzt schon weitere Hilfsmaßnahmen in die Wege leiden
oder Homeoffice-Strukturen, wo denn möglich, weiter ausbauen
und uns jetzt schon mal Gedanken machen,
wie wir irgendwie länger durchhalten.
Es ist ein Marathon.
Aber ich kann auch nicht verstehen, wie Menschen 42 Kilometer laufen können
und trotzdem schaffen sie es.
Deswegen, Freunde der Sonne, lasst euch nicht unterkriegen
und wenn ihr irgendwelche motivierenden Gedanken oder Ideen zur Ausdauer habt,
schreibt sie gerne in die Kommentare.
Ich hoffe, ihr seid gesund und ihr schlagt euch irgendwie tapfer
durch diese unwirkliche Zeit.
Mir geht es gut, das Baby ist da.
Es ist ein sehr, sehr süßes Freundchen der Sonne
und wir sind zum Glück alle gesund.
Aber mein Herz geht raus an
Kinder von KS.
Alle, die von Covid-19 getroffen sind, entweder selbst oder im Freundes- oder Familienkreis,
an alle, die sich gerade den Hintern aufreißen, um diesen Laden am Laufen zu halten,
die sich um unsere Gesundheit kümmern und um unsere Grundversorgung
und auch an alle, die jetzt gerade nicht arbeiten können oder nicht bezahlt werden.
Es ist wirklich eine verdammt heftige Zeit.
Zum Glück kann ich wenigstens MyLab von zu Hause aus produzieren.
42 Kilometer im Monat, easy.
Auch wenn wir im Team gerade etwas langsamer vorankommen,
weil sowohl Lars als auch Melanie ein Kita-Kind zu Hause haben.
Deswegen hat Melanie auch nicht geschafft, diese Folge Grafiken zu machen,
aber vielleicht habt ihr es gemerkt...
Oh, keine Grafiken, die Abo ist raus.
Nee, aber das Video war wirklich gut.
Das Video war echt gut.
So, was macht denn so Wodafone und Gerumgelegge?
Ach Gott, Wodafone, please.
Ich würde jetzt gerne mal wieder ein bisschen hochschalten können, meine Bitrate,
damit wir uns vielleicht noch das Modern Warfare Remaster Review angucken können.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Na?
Scheint so zu funktionieren, Leute.
Okay, wir probieren es mal, wir probieren es mal.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal das Modern Warfare Review an.
Ich bin mal gespannt, ob sie da wirklich viel remastert haben.
Ich glaube es ja erst, wenn ich sehe.
Aber eins muss ich sagen, der Soundtrack von Modern Warfare 2,
das war der beste der Serie bisher.
Itzhans Zimmer-Soundtrack.
Das ist eher, weil sich in der Reihe kaum was geändert hat, sieht das immer noch so gut aus.
Ich erkenne wenig Unterschied.
Doch, doch, doch, hier.
Also das Licht sieht schon deutlich besser aus als im Original.
Das Licht sieht schon besser aus, ja.
Und dazu kommt, dass ich ja Modern Warfare 2 auf der Xbox 360 gespielt habe.
Ich meine, es sah damals schon schlechter aus als auf PC.
Nein, kein Multiplayer.
Ach so, das kommt gar nicht auf den PC.
Na ja gut, Ende April, who cares.
Guckt euch mal die hässlichen Büsche an.
Seht ihr wie hässlich die Büsche aussehen?
Das war eine große Teil des Packages, die sehr vermisst werden.
Faster, mehr chaotisch als im Original, mit Herzschlag-Sensoren,
mehr elabere Perken und Killstreak-Rewards, die in den Taktik-Nuken ausgeliefert wurden.
Auch wenn wir natürlich das 2019-Reboot haben,
mit klassischen Maps aus älteren Spielen in die Rotation,
wäre es schön zu haben.
Auf der plus-Bereichung bekommt man eine no-holds-bar-Bereichung
auf einem tollen Kampagnenmode.
Und man verabschiedet sich darauf, alles MKs錳 тебя miterbural zu
stören.
Deshalb kommt dieBrianne auf den
Einer der besten Call of Duty-Kampagnen.
Für all its bombastic excess,
its silliness,
the story goes down a more subversive path than the original.
There's a real sense of brooding dread as a terrible modern war
moves to western soil,
all amplified by a hand-zimmer score
and in spite of its colourful palette.
Technically, it was groundbreaking for its time too.
A 60 FPS game built for last-gen PS3 and Xbox 360 hardware.
It had Infinity Ward firing on all cylinders to improve its animation systems,
map scale and detail on every stage over the original.
Every level felt grand-rich.
Scale.
Whatever you're gonna do, so do it far!
Slow-mo, slow-mo.
Is recreating that same sense of spectacle for a 2020 audience.
Now the setup is similar to the 2016 modern warfare remaster,
starting with resolutions.
On Xbox 360, for example,
we had a 1024x600 sub-HD presentation backed by 2x MSAA.
A setup that fit neatly within its 10MB of ED RAM
to give a solid, clear picture for its time.
Jump to today's consoles and base PS4, of course,
can smash this in pixel counts.
We'll have to see how MW2 looks on the Xbox One
with Backwards Compatibility.
I don't know if the resolution is higher.
I don't mean to make the resolution higher.
We'd have to compare the original on a PC with the remaster.
The resolution is between 360 and MW2.
And, of course, a huge leap over the last-gen standard.
The other console to look at is, of course, PS4 Pro.
This time you get a native 2880x1620 image
or 75% scale on each axis of a full 4K.
The result satisfies if you're running on an Ultra HD TV
and the entire pipeline is reworked to support HDR2,
which comes out beautifully on the licking flames on car wrecks
or the bloom across a midday sun.
As for Xbox One X, well, we'll have to see when that arrives.
A proper 4K picture would be in step with the power profile of the machine,
but we'll see.
It's worth noting that the original Modern Warfare Remaster still to this day
only runs at 1920x1080 on X,
while the regular Xbox One has a dynamic resolution that scales under that.
In all likelihood, the base console setup will stay in place,
but we'll see what X can pull off when it releases.
To the comparisons then.
As you can see, there's very little between the PS4 consoles outside of resolution.
Texture filtering quality gets a clear bump on Pro,
while much else remains the same.
Es sieht da links deutlich pixeliger aus.
...which may be incidental, is a difference to the mapping of tiles on the PS4 Pro
in the favela opening shot, creating a more 3D appearance.
Other than that, shadow map quality is higher all round on PS4 Pro.
Look at the edges here, and there are finer gradients towards the shadow edges.
This ranks among the more taxing settings of the original Remaster on PC,
so it's nice PS4 Pro is seemingly getting more than a simple res boost.
Otherwise, much of the level of detail for geometry is the same,
though you'll spot randomly placed debris appearing on one console rather than the other.
The upgrades next to Xbox 360 are obviously more striking.
It's hard to know where to begin really, when every facet of its visual design is upheaved by Benox in some way,
sometimes to a radical degree.
For one, in-engine cutscenes are redone entirely.
Check out this moment as we're picked up from the ground.
The characters will move based on reworked motion capture.
Depth of Field was included in the original,
but it's much higher quality on the Remastered Edition as well on the foreground character.
Camera framing is adjusted too,
and all-round obviously, characters are bolstered with higher polygon meshes with new textures for clothing,
made all more obvious in close-ups.
Check out the crisp new layer of snow on jackets during this Kazakhstan level opener,
a vastly higher resolution map, while skinships...
Every surface has been touched up, notably city environments.
This open run through Rio de Janeiro shows fresh tiles now lining the pavement,
and a darker tarmac material for the road itself.
Fencing, floor pots, and even trees lining the road are replaced with the high-grade additions.
Curiously, global lighting is adjusted, with the sun casting shadows in a slightly different angle,
though it's close enough to the original.
As for post-effects, Call of Duty keeps the screen relatively clear.
Wäre das nicht auch 2009 möglich gewesen?
Ja, nur mit dem Hinblick darauf, dass man es 2009 so entwickelt hat,
dass es eben auf der Xbox 360 gut läuft,
und es sich wohl nicht gelohnt hätte, ein paar Sachen einzubauen, die es nur auf dem PC gegeben hätte.
Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, 2009 war jetzt die PC-Hardware auch nicht so der absolute Wahnsinn.
Ja, man hätte das 2019 vielleicht nicht ganz so schön,
aber er hätte es auf jeden Fall deutlich schöner machen können, 2009, ja.
Und die PC-Version sieht ja auch deutlich besser aus.
Wir sehen nur Blumen und Lens-Flare während wir rund umgehen,
und ein rarer Motorenblur-Effekt, das sich während des Ski-Klicks anbindet.
Die mehr elaborate Dinge wie Depth of Field sind für die Cutscenes gehalten,
wo es mehr einen cinematischen Impakt macht.
Allein, die Schüsse sprechen für sich selbst.
Zwischen der 360-Spieler hier mit der PS4 Pro ist es ein Erleichter,
so leid es sich so erledigen zu sehen.
Also die Beleuchtung sieht viel besser aus.
Die Last-Gen-Konsolen, 360 und PS3, könnten an Punkten kämpfen, in der Performance.
60 FPS war immer das Ziel, aber die Kampagnen-Ambition könnte manchmal das Beste davon bekommen.
Ein Flashback zu Xbox 360 zeigt eine große Menge Gameplay,
das das Ziel mit Voll-V-Sync schützt.
Wir haben Troublespots, natürlich.
Die Fevella-Shootout-Beam-1, das Gu-Lag-Intro-Beam,
und vor allem, was mit Drone-Attacken von oben zu tun hat,
oder Explosionen von C4 mit vielen Gegnern zu tun hat.
Schließlich sind viele dieser Momente eine stille Kamera,
in der es nicht so deutlich erscheint, aber es gibt Exzeptionen.
Fevella hatten sie entfernt wegen dem Bild auf dem Klo ursprünglich mal,
aber die Kamera wird da rein.
Huge Aim.
Etwas, das in großen, sprachlosen Orten, wie die Strip-Mall
oder die mountain-topten Bunker in Kasachstan,
versuchte, den Kot vorzuhalten. Man muss den Kot nicht vorhalten.
Das war so eine bescheuerte Szene.
Naja, kann man sich vielleicht holen, aber ehrlich gesagt nur auf dem PC.
Also ich hole mir das garantiert nicht für die PS4.
Ich warte, bis es auf dem PC rauskommt.
Weil die Kampagne fand ich eigentlich ganz nett.
Zwar komplett übertrieben, aber fand ich eigentlich ganz nett.
Mehr Granaten in der Kampagne.
Auch MW2-Kampagne auf Schwere, da war der Granaten-Spam schlechthin.
Ja, das Backup ist sehr cool.
Also, ob das jetzt 25 Euro wert ist oder nicht, muss, denke ich, jeder selbst wissen.
Ich werde es mir vielleicht holen, um die Kampagne nochmal zu spielen.
Ich warte, 25 Euro ist jetzt zwar nicht wenig,
aber alternativ kannst du auch für 25 Euro jede Menge Crap-Steam-Early Access-Spiele geben, die noch beschissener sind.
Na gut, ich weiß, das ist kein Argument, nur weil es noch schlechter geht.
Aber wenn man mal wieder Bock auf die MW2-Kampagne hat, warum nicht?
Ja, bisschen teuer vielleicht, aber natürlich erst, wenn es auf dem PC rauskommt.
Logischerweise.
Ja, was gucken wir denn jetzt noch? Wir haben 30 Billionen Videos, die man gucken könnte.
Alle.
Das muss man mal kurz gucken, das fand ich lustig.
Das ist so richtig dumm in das Video. Das ist so richtig dumm.
Aber das muss man mal gucken, ich fand das lustig.
Die Stream-Theorie ist sowas wie die Stream-Theorie. Ganz einfach.
Das ist richtig, richtig dumm, richtig dumm.
Diese eine Stream-Theorie, die gibt's gar nicht.
So richtig dämlich, alle.
Also diese Theorien sind alle scheiße. Also die kompaktifizierten natürlich.
Genau.
Nun haben wir alle in der Schule gelernt, die Welt ist eine Kugel.
Aber die Experimente sagen genau das Gegenteil.
Denn die Welt ist eine Scheibe, die besteht wiederum aus Atombomben.
Wir selber bestehen aus Gitarrenseiten, die sind aus ein Gramm Saas zusammengebaut.
Der Saas, also nicht der Soos, sondern der andere, besteht aus Brot.
Dann hat man rausgefunden, weil man einen Kock immer tiefer und tiefer in dein Mutter gesteckt hat.
Das Brot nun aus Quark besteht, also wie die Stimme von 1 Froschen.
Und die Stream-Theorie sagt nun, das ist nicht das Anfang.
Das ist gewissermaßen erst der Ende.
Könnte auch sagen, eine Gedic-Digi.
Praktisch Digi.
Genau.
Könnte auch sagen, ein String-Tanga-Gottes.
Der Erwertungsrat der String-Theorie ist also, dass sich innerhalb des Elementarteichens Soos zeigt.
Ein bis offener String, wie man sehen kann.
Die Strings, das sind die elementarsten Elementarsteine des Elementarsums.
Allerdings auf einer Längenskala, wie man sich schon vorstellen kann.
Wenn ihr euch hier in den Finger schneidet und 1 Gramm Zeigefinger abschneidet,
Na, wer kennt sich?
dann habt ihr 10.000.000.000.000
35, 27 tausend Trillionen, drei, vier, fünf, sechs, elf Teilchen.
Daran kann man schon ahnen.
Kann man ahnen, dass also, dass alles wahnsinnig klein ist.
Wie der Schwanz von Donald Trump.
Da sind wir bei einer Ausdehnung von, ja, einem...
Was ist zu laut?
Trillionstel Meter, das ist so gut wie nix.
Das ist der kleinste Kock-Universum.
Also deutlich kleiner als meiner.
Der ist tausend Kilometer groß.
Eigentlich sogar die Größe von dem Abstand der Erde, Erde zum Mond.
Wenn ich's wirklich genau rechne.
Ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig, sich das vorzustellen.
Mit so n Schaft kann ich tiefer in die Bitches eindringen.
Ja, ja, genau.
So dämlich.
Wenn ich was sehen will...
Das fand ich echt gut geschnitten, ey.
Wenn ich das vorzustellen.
Mit so n Schaft kann ich tiefer in die Bitches eindringen.
Ja, ja, genau.
Wenn ich klar ist, wenn ich was sehen will,
dann will ich was sehen.
So.
Es gibt ja ne Reihe von von von von von von von von Experimenten.
Da war ja die große Hoffnung, dass man etwas findet,
was in den String-Tanga-Theorien absolut notwendig ist.
Nämlich, man braucht mehr Geländer als nur zwei hier.
Aber mehr als zwei Geschlechter gibt's gar nicht.
Er findet sich nix.
Es findet sich von diesen Theorien, die man bräuchte,
findet sich nix.
Nix.
Skix.
Völlig klar ist, wenn ich was sehen will, was es nicht gibt,
dann muss ich mehr Gras brauchen.
Dann bräuchte ich bereits paar Hunderttausend Gramm Gras.
Solche Chans kann ich gar nicht bauen.
Also mathematisch gesprochen ist es so,
wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel so n Schaftgesetz anschaut wie...
Ja, genau. Jetzt könnte man sich fragen, vielleicht ist dieses Gesetz gar nicht überall erfüllt,
sondern ab einer bestimmten Anbussdehnung gibt es vielleicht 1-3r hoch 3, 1-3r hoch 5,
1-3r hoch 5, 1-3r hoch Quadrat, 1-3r hoch Kugel, 1-3r hoch Fußgänger, 1-3r hoch Gott,
1-3r hoch Allah. Also das ist die große Frage. Sieht man sowas?
Also wenn es in Ebbes ein Erfolgsrezept gibt, der physikt dann doch das, dass wir immer
krass in die Toilette scheißen.
Sowas ficken nacktes, Alter.
Ich war dann übelst mutgemacht. Vor allem, ich will nicht wissen, wie lange hat er da
gesessen und das Video geschnitten. Das hat doch Stunden gedauert, bis du sowas raushast.
Big Schock. Es macht eigentlich Big Schock. Gibt es von ihm irgendwas Neues? Oh.
Bacon Sausage Cheeseburger. Nee, wir gucken jetzt kein Essen Video, weil ich hab Hunger.
Ich hab Hunger. Was haben wir sonst noch zu bieten?
Corporate Cringe. Ah, das ist zu cringy jetzt. Zu langes Video. Hatten wir schon? Hatten
wir schon? Nee, hatten wir noch nicht. BF Rush Video, please. Welches? Welches?
Wir hätten Battlefield 3, Hype Marketing, was hat... Ich guck eigentlich sonst wenig
Jackfrax. Aber früher die alten Battlefield Videos, das war echt nicht schlecht.
Dann hätten wir zu bieten Battlefield 3 was Peak Battlefield und wir hätten zu bieten
When Rush Was Good. Was davon wollen wir mal gucken?
Bestell was. Nee, ich hab noch was. Ich muss das nur aus der Küche holen. Rush.
When Rush Was Good. Haben wir das schon geguckt? Müssen wir mal gucken. Nee, haben wir nicht
geguckt. Oh, viel zu laut. Warum hat er den Game Sound zu laut? Der Game Sound ist viel
zu laut. Okay, kommt da jetzt noch irgendwas? Woran was erzählt? Nee. Okay, das ist kein
Video, woran was erzählt. Das ist doof. A Battlefield 3 Hype and Marketing Masterpiece.
Eure Killzone, das ging ja voll an mir vorbei.
Also man muss ja sagen, Battlefield 3 war ein Game, das hat rausgekommen mit einem
mega Hype und hat halt den Hype auch irgendwie gehalten. Ja, war's auch.
Ich erinnere mich dunkel dran. Das war nicht Warfighter. Das war das erste.
Das war das erste Reboot. Also der Reboot, das originale Metal of Honor, nicht Warfighter.
Das ging sogar halbwegs, das ging sogar. Warfighter fand ich schlechter.
Und jetzt asken wir für wie lange schon nach einem ordentlichen Battlefield Game und es
kommt nichts.
Ja, da hat er recht. Stimmt, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, wo du die Mission gesehen
hast, wo im Prinzip nichts passiert und dann das auf dem Hochhaus. Da gab's doch das Video,
wo sie Activision getrollt haben, wo das mit dem Activision Logo war, wo sie das Activision
Logo abgeschossen haben.
Ja, das war das erste Reboot.
Das war das erste Reboot.
Das ist witzig, mittlerweile ist es anders. Guckt euch den Battlefield 1 Trailer an. Battlefield
1 Trailer kam raus und alle so, OMG, da habt ihr sie noch alle. Und damals Battlefield 3
kommt raus, boah, ist das geil. Mit dem Unterschied, dass halt auch Battlefield 3 mega geil aussah
und halt übelst nach dem ausgesehen hat, was die Leute wollen und Battlefield 1 überhaupt
nicht. Nicht Battlefield 1, 5, 5, 5, ich mein 5, nicht 1, 5. Die Battlefield Benahmung macht
mich fertig. Ich mein nicht Battlefield 1, ich mein Battlefield 5. Battlefield 1 war ich
ja sogar in Berlin noch auf dem Event und habt es live gesehen. Ja, das war geil. Ich
mein Battlefield 5 meine ich. Mit dem Soldat mit dem Katana auf dem Rücken und die Frau
mit der Kralle.
Das ist typische Kokona Logik, Alter. Wir killen euch alle und bringen euch den Frieden.
So funktioniert's.
Dabei war das in der Kampagne übelst ätzend. Diese Szenen, die waren einfach viel zu lang.
In A-Kockkolben. In A-Kockkolben.
Das ist das, was die Fans anbelangt haben.
Und am Ende dieses Videos, ein Witz.
Part 2 wird am 16. März eröffnet.
Und wenn man die limited Edition von BF3 preordert,
bekommt man die Back to Karkund Expansion gratis.
Hm, bedeutet das, dass Back to Karkund
Battlefield Maps aus alten Spielen eröffnet wurde?
Keiner wusste sicherlich, aber das war das wahrscheinlichste Ergebnis.
Am 16. März eröffnet.
Ist das das, wo sie das Activision-Logo abschießen? Die haben irgendwie so einen Trollpost gemacht,
wo sie das Activision-Logo abschießen mit der Panzerfaust.
Genau, das haben sie irgendwann noch mal remake, wo sie das Activision-Logo da drüben auf dem Haus war.
An die, an die Mission kann ich mich überhaupt nicht erinnern.
Und die Mission war richtig. Die Mission fand ich so schlecht.
Ja, das war cool.
Das stimmt.
Gut ausgeschaut haben Battlefield-Spiele eigentlich schon immer.
Sagen wir mal so ab, ich meine das erste war halt aus der Zeit, dass er alles so ein bisschen pixelig und
vor allem eckig aus. Aber spätestens seit Battle Company sah Battlefield immer top aus.
Aber es gab noch eine letzte Freude für uns am Ende, dass das Gebäude überfallen und in den Helikopter fallen.
Mehr Snippets des Spiels, mehr Teases. Die neue Battlefield-Main-Theme schwimmt und wir sehen
Nachtzeit-Maps, Tank-Battles im Meer, Helikopter, Soldaten, die auf einem Helipad springen, Jett,
Doppelböse, die auf einem Helikopter fallen, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter,
Helikopter, Soldaten, die auf einem Helipad fallen, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter,
Helikopter, Soldaten, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter,
Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter, Helikopter,
E3, das größte Game-Show der Welt, ist auf dem Horizont.
Und der Buzzer für BF3 wird immer weiterholt.
EA sagt, sie werden einen spielbaren Builder für die Game-Show haben.
Aber wir haben viel mehr gesehen als das.
Am 6. Juni kommt ein neues Video online.
Und das ist unser erster Blick auf den echten, pre-Alpha-Multiplayer-Gameplay
auf Operation Metro.
Und ja, es sah fast so gut aus als ein Singleplay.
Ich kann mich da dran erinnern. Das war so geil. Metro-LAV, der überall stuck geblieben ist.
Und die Bäume, über die man nicht rüberspringen konnte.
Oh, ich ärgere mich, dass ich die Battlefield-3-Alpha-Gameplays damals gelöscht habe.
Und Jahre später wäre das bestimmt noch cool gewesen, was zu sehen.
Oh ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das war so ein typisches Wir feiern alles Video.
Ich habe das auf der Xbox gespielt und danach auf PC.
Das Springen hat ja bis zum Schluss nicht richtig funktioniert.
Warum lachen die Leute? Ich habe eine Granate durchgeworfen.
Was? Was war da dran jetzt lustig? What the fuck, was ist daran lustig?
Oh, es stichelt
Sein Spielstil, die Leute, die dort im Publikum sitzen, können den Spielstil überhaupt nicht
einschätzen, weil es Kacknoobs sind, Ober-Kacknoobs, wer in so einer Fernsehshow live im Publikum
sitzt, hat wahrscheinlich noch nie im Leben ein Rechner mit Battlefield drauf besessen.
Ich mag die Map nicht, ich weiß, ich bin ja jemand, der Firestorm und Caspian Border nicht
mag.
Die Map, wo alle drauf abgehen, aber ich, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh,
äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh,
Äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, äh, es ist wirklich nicht wahnsinnig earlier thread staring
3. Wäre das schon vor dem Launch?
Haben wir genug?
Nein. September 9.
Der night time trailer von guillotine geht live.
Es ist von xbox.
Xbox. Das war der xbox trailer.
Diese lichter waren alle fake, ne?
Diese lichter waren alle fake.
Die da. Die waren alle fake.
Das hat man gesehen, weil man reingegangen ist. Manche konnte man killen, das ist nicht aus, das war alles fake.
Ist das nicht das Spiel, das auf xbox 360 kommt?
Wir haben noch nie einen xbox 360 Gameplay gesehen.
Wir haben noch nie einen xbox 360 Gameplay gesehen. Wird es sogar auf dem Hardware laufen?
Wir glauben es dir nicht.
Also am September 16.
EA antwortete und ein Gameplay von guillotine wurde auf xbox 360 veröffentlicht.
Ja, es war 720p.
30 fps.
Aber es läuft.
Da ist die Probe.
Es sieht trotzdem ziemlich gut aus.
Aber DICE hat immer gesagt, dass das ein nächstes Gen-Engine war.
Aber weißt du was? Es war ein cooler Trailer.
Wir hatten ein paar Slow-Motion-Schockenblasen,
Konvois von Humvees und die Konsole-Spieler waren glücklich.
Für jetzt.
Zehn Tage später.
Eine Kollaboration.
Was macht Vinnie's Unleashed eigentlich?
Die sind ja seit fünf Jahren Funkstille irgendwie.
Trailer-Advert mit Jay-Zs Song 99 Problems.
Battlefield 3 ist cool.
Und am Ende des Trailers ein Slogan.
Geht über und über die Kuh.
Ein direkter Schuss auf Call of Duty Modern Warfare 3,
welches kurz nach BF3 veröffentlicht wurde.
DICE und EA fühlten sich sehr sicher mit diesem Trailer.
Das Beta für das Spiel geht live.
September 27.
Ah, ja, da wurde auch gesuchtet.
Ja, es ist die Metro-Mapper-Game.
Aber es ist die erste Chance für Fans, das Spiel auf einer großen Schale zu spielen.
Und letztendlich ging es zum Open Beta,
mit einem tollen Willkommen zum Open Beta-Trailer.
Und alles, was das gemacht hat, war,
einfach alle coolen Sachen auszuspielen,
die man im Spiel machen könnte.
Und ich denke, wir brauchen mehr Trailers wie diese heutzutage.
Ich denke, die Leute wollen diese Details und Informationen.
Sie werden es sehen.
Als der Launch des Spieles näher wurde
und BF3 die Fertigkeitslinie ansteigen wollte,
war es am 18. Oktober,
dass der neue Multiplayer-only-Trailer live geht.
Es ist unglaublich populär.
Und es zeigt uns mehrere Maps, die wir noch nie gesehen haben.
Vor allem fokussiert es sich auf Damavand Peak und No Shark and Alps.
Warte einen Sekunden.
Du sagst mir, dass das ein Multiplayer ist.
Und ich kann auf einem Helipad mit meinen Teammaten skydiven,
als Helikopter neben mir fliegen.
Unverkauft.
Es ist ein grosses vertikales Level,
das z.B. Tanks, Humvees, Helikopter in Tunneln.
Was ist das? Mission Impossible?
Oh mein Gott, ich muss dieses Spiel spielen.
Und mehr.
Rippenboote mit montierten Waffen auf ihnen.
Flugzeugfahrer.
Ich schaue an einen neuen Urban-Map in Paris,
der alles draußen ist.
Same Crossing.
Aber es gibt Wasser und Brücken,
und es ist ziemlich offen mit mehr Rubbel-Dropfen.
Und da ist das Nachtmap, das wir schon gesehen haben.
Und dann,
kurze Klumpen von den restlichen Maps
mit hohen Panning-Schotten.
Perfekt.
Dieses Multiplayer hat viel Content drin,
und Dyson EA wollte das wissen.
Und dann am Ende,
unser erster Blick nach Back to Kark und
die klassischen Battlefield-Maps,
die sich wiedererleichtert haben.
Und weißt du was?
Sie sehen auch sehr gut aus auf Frostbite 2.
Die BF2-Fans werden es lieben.
Jetzt, nachdem das letzte Trailer,
bevor es losgeht,
am 21. Oktober,
haben wir einen neuen Trailer,
welcher live geht.
Und ehrlich gesagt,
denke ich, dass das einer der besten
Videogame-Trailers, die jemals veröffentlicht wurde.
Einige der Transitionen
und das Video-Kontent,
das ist alles unglaublich.
Das Audio ist super.
Schau dir das an,
und versuch nicht,
die Idee des Spiels zu spielen,
die in deinem Kopf riecht.
Shame!
Du kommst in unser Land, um uns zu töten.
Aber wir sind die Terroristen.
Das war der Trailer.
18 Stunden vor,
bekomme ich einen Anruf
von Homeland Security,
der sagt,
es gibt einen Marines,
mit dem ich reden muss.
Meine Damen und Herren,
wissen Sie,
dass wir uns mit den Insurgenten
von Iran befinden?
Wollen Sie uns glauben,
dass es eine PLO-Bedarfung gibt
und Solomon am Kopf ist?
Du bist die schnellste Reaktion-Forbe,
meine Damen und Herren.
Wir glauben,
dass Sie uns handeln können.
Der Nuke ist noch da.
Du kannst nicht einfach
von der Bedeutung weglaufen.
Lass uns unsere Marines finden.
Lass uns auf den Boden!
Ich sagte,
lass uns auf den Boden!
Der Trailer war richtig gut, ja.
Die Flugzeugmission
war halt ziemlich lame.
Ich meine,
cool gemacht war der Shot.
Das ist nicht ein Trial.
Du bist schuldig.
Ich weiß,
wie deine verdammte Geschichte ist.
Wow,
es ist politisch,
wütend,
taktisch,
episch,
es hat IR-Skope,
die Freundschaft.
Ich glaube,
ich habe den Trailer
ca. 50 Mal gesehen.
Das habe ich auch oft geguckt.
Man kann sich gar nicht vorstellen,
dass die Leute,
die daran gearbeitet,
eventuell auch an dem
Battlefield-5-Trailer gearbeitet haben.
Wenn das Game heute rausgekommen wäre,
da wäre definitiv mindestens einer
der beiden Verhörer eine Frau gewesen.
Garantiert.
Weil in dem Ganzen,
ich glaube,
in der ganzen Kampagne
kam irgendwie nicht eine.
Doch,
die Helikopter-Pilotin,
nee,
warte mal,
das war Modern Warfare
mit der Helikopter-Pilotin,
ne?
Kam in Battlefield 3 eine Frau vor?
Ich überlege gerade,
gab es doch irgendwie in der Kampagne
irgendeine Frau?
Die Jet-Pilotin,
na klar,
die Jet-Pilotin,
stimmt,
die hat man nicht gesehen.
Zivilisten gab es ein paar,
aber ansonsten so in der Kampagne
nicht wirklich.
Aber wenn das Game heute rausgekommen wäre,
hätten sie garantiert mindestens
einer der beiden Verhörer,
Verhörer-Leute wäre eine Frau gewesen.
Ja,
die,
die Pilotin war oder war eine Frau?
In der Mission.
Das war das.
Ah, ja.
Das war,
das war der schwächste DLC.
Armored Kill war nicht gut,
die Rushmaps haben gesackt und
vieles was da war irgendwie,
die AC-130-Missionen waren auch,
also die AC-130-Sachen
waren auch für den Arsch.
Aftermath war geil.
Endgame war auch gut.
Aftermath hatte richtig gute Maps.
Aftermath war gut.
Ja,
Und dann war es wirklich am nächsten Ende,
standen die Töne von ihren Tönen aus.
Jedes Schritt des Weges war immer ein Tee,
eine andere Karotte auf einem Stick
und es hat einfach so gut funktioniert.
Ich und viele andere werden immer
sehr gute Erinnerungen von Battlefield 3.
Hätte ich mich wahnsinnig drüber gefreut,
bei Battlefield 5 gehts mir am Arsch vorbei.
Das war aber echt ein gutes Video,
das hat sich gut gepasst.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ich hab Übels Kohldampf.
Jetzt Battlefield Hardline Videos,
nee, nee, nee, nee.
Ich zeige euch jetzt nochmal einen richtig
geilen Chrome Hack.
Man kann die hier alle markieren, alle Tabs.
Und dann geht man hier oben hin und sagt,
nee, man geht, fuck,
ich hab vergessen, wie es geht.
A book mark all tabs.
Und dann macht man hier mal einen neuen Ordner.
Keine Ahnung, drei, weil guter Name.
Und schon hat man hier in drei
alle Tabs gespeichert,
dass wir das nächste Mal weiter gucken können
an der Stelle und ich die Videos nicht vergesse.
Ah, das ist Big Brain.
Das, was im Nachhinein
Battlefield 3 halt irgendwie ausgezeichnet hat,
ist,
es war nie die Luft raus.
Es war nie die Luft raus.
Du hast zwar manchmal ausgelockt, weil es sich abgefuckt hat,
du hast vielleicht auch manchmal zu viel am Stück gespielt,
aber dann hast du mal kurz Pause gemacht
und hast gleich wieder Bock weiter zu spielen.
Es war nie so richtig die Luft raus.
Was ich halt bei Battlefield 1
und vor allem Battlefield 5 nicht sagen kann.
Battlefield 1 habe ich mir gar nicht gekauft
und Battlefield 5 fand ich okay.
Am Anfang am Anfang,
ich hab mir gesagt,
ich habe mir gesagt,
im Anfang aber es hat mich nicht so richtig,
wie sagt man so schön, gecatched.
Nie so das.
Also
Wir müssen nicht
Battlefield 3 wieder beleben,
die müssen ein ordentliches neues Battlefield machen.
Und wenn ich daran denke,
dass das jetzt
noch über ein Jahr dauert,
bis auch event, bis nur das nächste
Battlefield angekündigt werden wird,
Da habe ich so keinen bock drauf
Klauen fanatik ich glaube das war das gesamtpaket in battlefield 3 und vor allem weil man in battlefield 3 auch richtig gemerkt hat
Battlefield 3 war ein game man musste sich ein bisschen mit beschäftigen nicht übertrieben viel das ist also kein das ist jetzt kein
CS gewesen wo du halt um richtig gut zu werden auch wahnsinnig viel spielen musstest du musstest in battlefield 3 wirklich
erst mal schon gut mit dem game beschäftigen und ja du wurdest danach wenn ich mir angucke wie die hexe spielen natürlich immer noch
besser aber es hat schon gereicht wenn du nicht mal
wenn du wenn du kack noob warst und hast dich ein bisschen mit dem game beschäftigt konntest du schon ganz gut zerstören
das war halt auch ein guter faktor in battlefield 3
weil man konnte sich auch auch auf eine sache konzentrieren manche haben nur heli geflogen manche nur chat geflogen manche übelste
panzer action manche infanterie gespielt das hat auch so viele facetten gehabt
Battlefield wird eingestampft dafür verkauft der kram noch zu viel
da wir gucken nicht das war es noch ein video oder habe ich keinen bock drauf
Dank corona sind die server wieder voll in battlefield 3 ok gucken wir mal
Schauen wir mal
Server
So also nach was suchen wir wir suchen nach
Rush und wir suchen nach server wie moment man muss
Irgendwie musste so ganz komisch suchen dass es funktioniert
Na ja so voll ist das ganze nicht
Na ja es gibt noch ganze drei russserver guckt man bei conquest ich gucke mal allgemein
Mit conquest ist ein bisschen mehr dabei
Es gibt auch ein bisschen mehr
Es gibt auch noch team deathmatch zeig mal hier was haben wir denn
FTF squad deathmatch spielt es noch jemand?
Tatsächlich
Conquest
Conquest gibt es auch noch ein paar
Conquest gibt es auch nicht so viele sachen
Also sag mal so man findet man findet genug server um zu spielen aber viel ist es nicht
Richtig viel ist das nicht battlefield 4 ist deutlich besser besucht
Sucht man conquest large was large es gibt doch gar kein conquest large hier oder doch
Guck mal da da gibt es ein bisschen mehr
Da gibt es ein bisschen mehr also das ist so alles spielbar hier rush und conquest large
Die map die hier habe ich auch immer gespielt der server auf dem habe ich immer
Dings hier wenn ich battlefield 3 gespielt habe ich immer gespielt weil 64 spieler sind für rush zuviel
48 ist ok 32 persönlich lieber 48 geht 64 ist zuviel für rush auf den maps
Zeig mal deine stats von der 360 über den battle log
Bin ich das xbox ich hatte sie auf allen ich habe sie auf allen plattformen
Oh ich bin jetzt freund mit dem zebaro erstmal 12 kd eats habt ihr schon ordentlich
Gewonnen das ist mein 360 profil spielzeit haben wir 207 stunden gar nicht so viel
M16 easy mode easy mode easy mode wo sieht man die kd ich will meine kd sehen wo ist meine kd
2,56 also ich wenn das hier stimmt war ich wohl gar nicht so übel
Punkte Minute Sieg Niederlage Quote Spray in Brey manche Sachen habe ich nie frei gespielt
Das war schon nice 12% präzision klar M16 Spray da brauchen wir keine präzision für
Kannst du dein battle log profil angucken kann wenn du willst kann ich das machen ja
Du musst mir nur mal sagen wie dein battle log profil heißt oder so wie dein twitch
Name was kuss swat ups battle log
Zauberst auf russischer en
Ja du hast ein wenig ein wenig mehr gespielt würde ich sagen
Zeig mal hier aufträge Du hast du hast ja wahrscheinlich erstmal alles alles fast alles
freigespielt einfach einfach alles anlockt Aber auch hier besten Waffen wieder hier am
Start was hast du hauptsächlich gespielt
Hast du viel hast du viel chat oder sowas gespielt ah yes
Du hast Flugzeug und und teleaction gemacht ja ja dann ist klar ja dann ja dann haltet
ich auch eine vierer kd wir gucken uns jetzt nicht von allen leuten hier die battle logs
an mit f ich glaube euch dass ihr alle die richtig krassen owner seid
Sollte auch kein flex sein die das passt schon und selbst wenn du könntest damit ja sogar
flex ist ja kein schlechtes profil
So leute ich gehe jetzt essen und aufs klo ich habe hunger vor allem wenn ich sowas sehe
wir sehen uns vielleicht morgen aber auf jeden fall die woche irgendwann wieder weil home
office beste home office heißt ich bin direkt nachdem ich in der arbeit fertig bin daheim
und kann striebern machen
Wie viel gigabyte download ich glaube so 15 oder 20 oder so battle field 3 war ohne addons
nicht so groß
Was machen eigentlich die stats gehts jetzt wieder ja
Wir lassen das bild erstmal da oben drin
So du folgst wem folge ich dann alles
Und wer könnte nen host gebrauchen von den leuten den ich folge
Keiner da der es wirklich gebrauchen würde
Gut leute dann machen wir Schluss wir sehen uns kommt heute ein battle field video wenn
ich mich jetzt endlich dazu aufraffen kann ich wollte dieses wochenende machen wenn ich
mich endlich dazu aufrufen kann ähm aufraffen kann das mal zu machen dann kommt das heute
Haben wir noch offene fragen muss ich grad mal gucken
Wie kann man bei deiner i3 tmox terminal scrollen
Äh steuerung b bild hoch und runter
ffm pack
World war 3 hätte so geil werden können ja das habe ich mir sogar early access geholt
und nach zwei runden nicht mehr gespielt falls da irgendwie nix drinne war so richtig und
jetzt ist glaube ich auch nicht besser warfmeier habe ich noch nicht probiert
Na das ist feels bad man
Oma aufgaben was ich leg jetzt kein links an
boah weiß ich nicht mehr
Moin max du hast doch vor einiger zeit mal ein tv herdanzer verheiratet wie hieß dein
tuner noch mal
Oh das war irgendein winwin tv dual tuner stick
Weiß ich jetzt auch aus dem kopf nicht mehr genau
Okay leute wir sehen uns machts gut bis zum nächsten mal see you